two left right
that's right
[Music]
i don't even know if i'm allowed to do
that anymore why because i
appropriated it no no that's right
that's like that's white culture it is
white culture that's right that is
quintessential white culture i know
well i think you know here on the
leftovers we this is basically a
i say here at the leftovers let the race
wars begin oh okay okay temple
temple immediately by the way as soon as
i got banned he'd dm me like yo i will
pay whatever you want you know hotel
fees everything like you know come on my
show please
of course he wants you to come on his
show yeah how about what is with temple
like can you just use zoom bro
i mean yeah i'm not like flying
first of all after i saw that rv [ __ ] no
okay i am not sitting in that thing
that's the omicron they call that the
omicron box right there that [ __ ] looks
like that yeah it's just i know it
smells strange in that rv you know what
i mean yeah it smells crazy
you know flaming turkey i heard that joe
rogan's nipples actually leave a pungent
odor wherever they are so dude don't get
me started on joe rogan's nipples okay i
i've i've said before that i'll suck on
them shits you tuck that there's
probably some liquid to get out of those
yeah if you suck
i would take i would take the trt right
out of his nips
you would go you would start growing
as you suck well the conversation on my
on my chat
alright chat i miss you so much but the
conversation on those oh yeah yeah
conversation originally started because
someone was like would you lick joe's
bald for medicare for all i was like
[ __ ] yeah
you know would you lick his dome
yeah i'd like him for everybody health
insurance yeah you wouldn't [ __ ] his
dick for that yeah i was just about to
say yeah
not even a question right yeah um and
then i was like i'd i would
you know suckle on his nipples
recreationally
yeah
yeah i'm curious what those milkers are
like yeah
well anyway guys texture probably
today we are live this is the leftovers
episode 11. it's also the last episode
of the year yeah
because we're taking a short break
next week is a short week it's our last
week so we'll be back
uh
we will be back the week of the 17th of
january
so assuming it goes up on sunday that
would be the 23rd there you have it a
little break a little break that's a big
break dude
it's a little break people need their
fix oh my god
it's it's a little break it's it's it's
a little break i need it so bad bro
you guys yeah i i
i'm already on a on a forced break at
the moment yeah let's talk about [ __ ]
hate it dude yeah okay so first of all
today's spon we're sponsored by harry's
razors and stamps.com you're on what has
it only been three days and you're
already coming here like a freaking
crackhead i'm i'm losing my mind yeah
i'm just like itching
yeah i just
people think like oh yeah you stream
because you make a lot of money like
sure making a lot of money is great but
like i'm an addict like i love streaming
i'm built for it i i've been training
every day now though at least with my
trainer and i i realize like i catch
myself i just like go on tangents while
i'm working out about like nancy pelosi
you know coming out and like talking
about yeah coming out i'm like talking
about how like oh no people and they're
you know congress persons and their
spouses should be able to trade uh
stocks i'm like and it's [ __ ]
[ __ ] and you know and
and that's you know does your trainer
give a [ __ ] he's like no he loves it he
thinks he's [ __ ] hilarious he's like
i get my news from you which is great
you know god bro i can't believe you're
doing a private show for your trainer
yeah you should be paying me now you
know yeah people pay you a lot of money
for that
content well listen his song was banned
for a week
for the use of the very offensive word
cracker yeah
which is a slur against white people
we're cracking down of course yeah
um and so we've planned a very special
episode to commemorate uh this very
offensive word cracker which we're
giving it a fond farewell apparently
we're
no longer allowed to use the word
cracker at least on twitch
yeah and uh directionally like you can't
call someone a cracker that's the that's
the point you can say cracker uh yeah
you can you can still be like i'm
purchasing some ritz crackers you know
they're not like oh there it is but as
far as i understand they're taking a
hard stance against you know
all of the most important what if you
say cracker with the
soft er not like a hearty or like
cracker
dude i i don't know i'm pretty sure you
still can't you can't say kraka yeah i
don't think you say with the soft day
either
you can you can i think twitch lets you
rap along with it though if it's in a if
it's in a rap song lyric i think you can
say okay that's good as long as yeah as
long as we still have that yeah
yeah because you know i mean i
understand hitting the hard er on that
word
yeah it's completely unacceptable
well we have a bunch of games planned we
have uh
later on the white slur tier list where
we're going to
put all of our favorite white slurs and
a tier list of how offensive we might
think they are and i think what's
interesting about that is i don't think
cracker is even going to top that list
no
um definitely not especially because
like
when you when you say like the c word
the funniest thing that has happened so
far this entire past week is that like
people have been trying to be like oh
yeah cracker is unacceptable it's like a
white racial term or whatever
and it's a slur and it's you know really
[ __ ] up you should stop saying it and
then they'll try to be like yeah that's
why it's like they're trying to call it
the c word right and it's like the
fourth worst c word so like there's like
three other actual c words that are way
worse than cracker
and and there is a c word you cannot say
on youtube or you'll get instant
demonetized oh really that would be the
c word that's used as a derogatory term
for women oh the see you next tuesday
yes
wait no way you cannot say that on
youtube wait doesn't does that mean
youtube is anglophobic
because like that's that's a part of the
vernacular for australians that's what i
said i i i this happened to his research
i said that word
and then they're like boom yellow you
can't say that it's uh it's like
derogatory for women i'm like dude what
are you talking about like in in england
and australia they say that word like
it's damn having a cup of tea i called
jake tapper that one time
like because he was trying to be like
you need to apologize to every woman
that works in the media for using that
word and i was like you're the head that
word oh really was that on that wasn't
on air was it this was like a long this
was like
months ago maybe a year ago it was on at
this point
no he was upset on twitter
god you cut you're you're bringing a lot
of ire lately
yeah this was i mean i've always been
this way though that's the thing like
not me though not like me i don't cause
anything yeah you're you're you're very
yeah you're not nobody mad at me right
now yeah there's no there's no lawsuits
coming your way ever it's good it's
great being sued three times
yeah
and uh
didn't [ __ ] up yesterday either
about anything
i don't even know what happened
well
don't worry about it everyone watching
does
oh no there was a i i said i opened up
uh
i don't want to i i made a comment about
the
uh moses's uh wife
oh
oh okay that uh oh no got me in some
trouble oh no with you know so that's it
i can't talk about it anymore yeah yeah
no i i feel that it's usually best to
just not
wait what the hell is that it's moses's
wife oh okay oh yeah
yeah and she and you know why it was hot
bro zipporah you know and this she's a
moment she's a great woman i shouldn't
uh
disparage her definitely not
and interestingly uh ethiopian she looks
white
was moses's mother a cracker
oh god
we're starting off strong today
my my latest episode of the podcast i
call benjamin franklin a cracker oh he
was definitely i mean he was 100 yeah
yeah that's you know he thought germans
were swarthy like he was like an anglo
supremacist
that's the beautiful thing about
whiteness is that
it's not real it's made up yeah like
there's no other group of people that i
can think of where they say oh i'm this
and it's actually meaning like a group
of totally separate distinct cultural
and national identities yeah
like you don't
usually
you just when you want to dunk on
someone in europe you don't go like oh
you're a cracker you're just like you
get real racist about their ethnic
background you know what i mean or you
it's not even racist yeah it's like yeah
if you go to europe they're like oh [ __ ]
you know [ __ ] the italians [ __ ] yeah
exactly the english yeah you know
but i think a lot of white people they
they get confused because there is
the african-american which is a distinct
group of people because of their shared
experience being brought here as slaves
and you know they the heritage of
growing up uh you know under those
conditions and
yeah being robbed of their ethnic
identity their shared culture they don't
have their lineage their language they
they had
black culture in america is
uh made up through intergenerational
trauma that they experience and also the
contemporary elements of said trauma and
the culture i mean they have a distinct
culture they're black americans they're
african-americans they might what their
heritage might be from different
countries in africa but like
their identity is their their black
americans so i think some white people
look at that and confuse themselves and
say oh no well we're white people in the
same way it's like no you're dude you're
[ __ ] like uh but that's that's not
new for the record like that is when you
think about white power for example
um white power came after black power
like this is white identity politics
have always been utilized by white
supremacist white nationalists in a way
to you know dupe liberals that are in
the margins into believing that their
cause is also just because most liberals
who uh come from a place of empathy look
towards things like that and go well
yeah that does kind of make sense all
lives matter does kind of make sense but
it's like no that's actually a
reactionary movement against black lives
matter that's really uh i think that's a
good
explanation for kind of what twitch is
doing and just to kind of tell people
who don't know uh hassan
was basically yeah banned for saying the
word calling someone a cracker yeah
commenter the thing is twitch um
twitch is super liberal and so i think
what they're doing is exactly what you
said where they're like well crackers
you know we don't want to talk up
disparage people based on their skin
color but at the same time what they're
doing
by making cracker a word you cannot say
or call people anymore there is giving
oxygen breathing life into you know the
the uh
white identity politics and the white
grievances where they say now they have
something to point to and say see look
we are martin we are marginalized yeah
and now you can say cracker on twitch
anywhere that's proof and that's why it
can be that that's why it can be like
someone who is caught up in this
thinking like well yeah it does kind of
make me feel bad it is a racial uh
racially targeted term
all the way to like
if you look through my replies or if you
look through like the reddit comment
there's like people straight up being
like
racist as hell because most of the
people that engage in that or at least
like the advocates for that kind of
white grievance and white identity
politics are themselves usually either
hiding their power level if you will
they're just still white supremacist of
white nationalists
not saying that like if you are offended
by the term cracker you are a white
supremacist i'm not saying that at all
but the main people that uh champion a
cause like that in ninety percent of the
circumstances are white and uh white
nationalists and white supremacists who
do believe that uh there is a legitimate
grievance there and that white people
are under attack yeah i mean there's no
there's kind of no people who are
actually offended by the word cracker
really
is a
symptom of
something it can only come from like
actual white nationalism where it's like
we're under attack we're being displaced
we're being replaced the great
replacement these are the white crisis
right like these are
the white quote unquote white problems
and they're all super racist they're all
super
xenophobic and reactionary and this is
where these grievances come from and
nowhere no other place other than as
you've appropriately identified white
people are oppressed routinely based on
class yeah
you know or based on all the forms of
marginalization like they could be
oppressed because of their religious
backgrounds they could be oppressed
because of their their sexuality
or their gender but
never because exclusively because
they're white um
that's just not a thing that has
happened historically because it's not
tied to any sort of historic or
contemporary form of oppression
unless you consider straight up like
someone making fun of you to be a
legitimate form of oppression and
struggle right and i think that that is
really reductive
and kind of silly
because it's like
the holocaust is bad not because like
people were making fun of jewish people
you know what i mean or or slavery was
bad but it wasn't bad because people are
making fun of black people like that's
not
real that's not real oppression that
you're experiencing it's not a real
struggle that you're experiencing on the
virtue of being white yeah so i think
that's something we have to be mindful
of is why
this attempt to make cracker into a
naughty word is actually serving the
interests of uh
radical uh reactionary uh white
supremacists i mean that's it so yeah
and i do worry it's interesting and yeah
i mean it's it's funny because twitch is
really
and their wokeness is actually
serving serving the uh
serving the wrong master i don't know
how to say it but i also don't want it
to be like
like look it's still it's still making
fun of someone right uh and you know it
can get out of hand i recognize that and
i also it's not like i use the term
regularly you know what i mean until uh
two of my moderators got banned for
chatting it you know what i mean they
weren't even what happened right to
moderator so tell me what happened
they were watching masterchef one of my
moderators uh
said uh get [ __ ] cracker or something
like that i think it was that they just
typed it out in chat and immediately
they got banned another one of my
moderators was saying like well cracker
is not a slur what the [ __ ] they got
banned two in a in a sequence of like a
couple minutes and i found that to be
really strange because like if they had
typed that in any other chat where
there's not like active twitch staff in
the chat at all times and one of the
largest uh content creators on the
platform they wouldn't have been fine
like people type way worse [ __ ] in other
people's chats
on a on a daily basis so i i felt like
they were
targeted in that circumstance
exclusively because they are moderators
of someone who is a high-profile
political commentator and i wanted to
defend them i i thought that it was
[ __ ] that they got but it doesn't
even seem like especially the second guy
yeah just like what was that yeah they
got hit with like 30 day bands and
the irony of course is that like the
same lsf and and all these other like
commentators on reddit or the commenters
on reddit that normally would be like
all about chatters rights
totally forgot about the fact that these
guys were banned for chatting
and hyper focused on how much they uh
despised me for being a quote-unquote
hypocrite about this issue something
that i why are you a hypocrite because
you're against slurs but you're in favor
of using yeah yeah yeah exactly and
that's that's where this is the one that
popped me this is what this is the one
that got you banned yeah all right let's
watch you
why
it's not the same in the video that you
refused to watch and just wrote that
argument against who are you arguing
against who asked
who said this
did i say oh my god salty and cracker
like people are just bitter because it's
salty cracker that's not what i'm that's
not what i said you dumb cracker [ __ ]
okay
you
like they're they're wait can you say
you dumb [ __ ] to people on twitch yeah
you can i'm pretty sure because i don't
know what their policy is
it's just like it depends on if it's
high profile or not that was high
profile in that circumstance a lot of
people had already like started getting
fake angry or very actually very real uh
outraged uh because they got whipped up
into a [ __ ] frenzy or because they
legitimately think it's the worst thing
that they've ever heard i don't know
um and when that happens like twitch of
course pays special attention to a
situation like that
and i'm sure that the very same problem
would occur if i was causing a [ __ ]
because then
it's like you're defending the right to
be able to say a mean thing right
and ultimately i do recognize that it's
like cracker is still a mean thing right
it's just not bandworthy that was my
argument
so that was what you're saying you would
have been banned for calling someone a
[ __ ] or no in a situation like this i
mean i doubt it because like reddit will
never be like i can't believe he said
someone is a [ __ ] right you know
whatever you think the outrage machine
is what resulted in you getting the ban
oh for sure i think the outrage machine
uh is what laser focused on this so but
like i guess it's it's it's easy to look
at that and say it is mean you know just
call someone cracker is a mean way to be
like to
dismiss someone
yeah to say like hey your opinions don't
matter because you're white i mean that
that's you know that's that's not i've
been a recipient of that many times yeah
that's not nice like okay you know but
but clearly we have to put some kind of
benchmark here for for what makes
a hate a hate crime or something to rise
to that because
like as you'll see when we do the
the
well so far the people that agree with
twitch were gab like gab literally
tweeted out about how like you know yeah
you know twitch is uh of course there's
gonna be 90 of the hate crimes on the
internet or anti-white hate crimes well
twitch is gonna find out real soon that
the people who are
rallying against them are going to be
you know the usual suspects of uh just
the worst people the worst group of
people
on the internet that you would never
want to associate with the basically
lightly veiled white supremacists
or just fully unmasked ones and they're
gonna i don't know
it just seems it seems insane to me but
let's move on here um
oh yeah this was good watch this i
posted this you'll get a kick out of
this
i posted this on um
twitter by the way just to show you the
difference between youtube
and twitch
[ __ ] youtube by the way stan youtube
[ __ ] tr you had a gamer moment bro
yeah and they trended your ass on gaming
for the crowd i was i was on the i was
on the pub g bridge dude you you had a
gamer moment i was on the pub g bridge
throwing out slurs dude is that awesome
though like that's gotta kind of be cool
to see like well youtube don't give a
[ __ ]
yeah it was the first time i've ever
trended on youtube i think it's awesome
right
you know youtube was like yeah we love
we love
we love when you get banned from gamer
words
but it's not it's not a gamer it's not a
real thing we're being sarcastic um and
so that was funny but here you'll get a
kick out of this on our subreddit
i made this twitter post that i guess
got a lot of uh points here
i used to do white face as a gag in our
old videos and i'm like when i did that
you need to issue a trigger warning
before you drop a white face like that
this is this is so hate trigger warning
to people who are sensitive to white uh
struggles
um it's just ridiculous to anyone who or
people with uh who are afraid of having
new uh night paralysis demons
i mean yeah i i yeah i got pied in the
face as well so i'm i i did a little bit
of white face earlier this week right
after i got banned but the thing you're
absolutely correct on your your
sentiment
when i did this
many times i thought this is funny and
nobody will be offended like the thing
was
is that i was like nobody will be
offended by me doing white face nobody
i know and nobody was and now i'll say
nobody was offended just wait now i'm
sure now people are going to be like oh
that's really [ __ ] up dude i'd love to
see that i mean
nobody was offended when i did white
face because a stupid joke with no real
consequences and no history of
oppression twitch banning crackers
giving auction to white identity
politics and putting white grievances on
equal footing with actual press people
okay whatever so here's my tweet now
here's the funny part is that uh i guess
it reached the front page of reddit
because i had 20 000 points
and here's a list here's all the uh
reports we got i don't know what people
think when they report stuff like where
did they think it goes to i mean is
promoting hate based on identity
vulnerability there's not a hate
subreddit unproductive toxic post this
is misinformation
targeted harassment of someone else it's
targeted harassment at me
it's sexual or suggestive content
involving
oh they're just like throwing darts at
the board you know
spam
hate speech uh what's an insult based on
skin color
uh reporter snooze what does that mean
whatever i don't know i tried to when
you click on it let's you undo it but
that one won't do it so i think uh they
withdrew their report or something i
don't know
this comment section is a mess okay dude
they're just like
this is the one way that a lot of
extremely online people can like hype up
a narrative and make it seem like it's a
it's a legitimate one
and that's precisely what they did here
and for a couple days this [ __ ] trended
on reddit you know it
made it to our all a bunch of times
and i was looking at like subreddit
drama and all these other like
subreddits that hyper focus on uh you
know or or whenever it was like
cross-posted like on your subreddit
it was cross-posted and people would be
like this is laughable what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you and then the person who
posted it would be like what do you mean
it's laughable it's not this is a
[ __ ] this is a disaster and it's like
no normal people when they see that go
oh yeah that's funny and move on with
their lives
i refuse to believe and i i
nobody has ever been offended by the
word cracker i would say for the most
part
you know it can be mean but nobody i'll
tell you what if somebody passed me on
the street and said hey cracker i'd be
like okay if somebody's called me the k
word you know for jewish people like a
strong slur
that that would upset me that that
that's yeah because
historic oppression it's stupid it's
super anti-semitic it's super hateful
and that's something that actually would
would hurt and something that i think is
is very racist but calling me a cracker
is like
cool dude well have a good day
yeah no it's it's like
it it's ridiculous and uh the same goes
for someone like myself you and i are
both uh
cracker adjacent yeah correct or i'm not
representing i am i i'm [ __ ] white
right like this is something i say all
the time yeah it would be laughable if i
ran around saying i'm a person of color
like i'm palestinian
i feel the same way but we're cracker
presenting so yeah we're white passing
and we're white like i'm just i'm white
right
and uh that definitely uh factors into
conversations about race whenever i you
know am at odds with like a particular
group on twitter like nicki minaj stains
or whatever that's like the number one
thing is like oh see your white ass out
of black people's business yada yada and
it's like no i mean
i won't so i don't really give a [ __ ]
but ultimately like that doesn't that
doesn't mean anything it's meaningless
it's laughable i've been called the
cracker a million times and and numerous
other things like that and it's nowhere
near as impactful as you know being
called the sand n word or being compared
to terrorists regularly which even then
i don't really give a [ __ ] but that's
just me but i totally do understand
because there is contemporary struggle
and systemic oppression associated with
being dehumanized on the virtue of your
religious identity uh and you know the
patriot act and all this other stuff
that the american government is engaging
in on a regular basis
well i think this next game will really
drive home the point we're trying to
make
so i'm introducing our first cracker
event of the day should we do ads first
dan
we're at 25. let's do it yeah let's do
it first but here we've made this is
super exciting the cracker
tearless
most offensive words for white people
we're going to sort this once and for
all we've got some really fantastic
things here on deck but before that
uh let's thank our spawn or well yeah
we're live we have to thank our sponsors
at the end
all right we got two here thank you so
much sue harry's
razors
yes yes let's face it guys are hard to
shop for whoever you're getting a gift
for this season you know we want
something exciting but practical this
year give them harry's there's no better
gift than the limited edition holiday
shave set featuring their award-winning
winston handle plus handsome ready to
gift packages for an amazing unboxing
moment books are great ties are great
socks are great but the guy in your life
also do deserves something he'll use
every single day for years to come
and that's why i bought mayman a
flashlight
what it doesn't say that just kidding
okay
i don't know i'm just trying to spice it
up
because i don't shave every day
yeah me either i use a fleshlight every
day as well can you imagine do you no
okay i know i said that i mean look what
is it harry's got like that that thick
handle you can use that as a weapon at
least yeah lady [ __ ] hand even if
you're not shaving you can use that as a
weapon so you can use it every day
harry's is the gift that keeps on giving
their sharp and long-lasting blades are
still as low as two bucks each
when it's finally time to replace them
how often can you say you're giving the
gift of saving
for a limited time
not nearly enough no listeners of my
show can get five dollars off any
holiday shave set at harrys.com
leftovers love the harry's blade it's
weighty it doesn't give me razor burn
it's just a beautiful [ __ ] razor that
gets the job done
affordable
beautiful we love that high quality fair
price their blades last long they're
german engineered award-winning backed
by 100 gear uh quality guaranteed so if
he doesn't love his shave you get a full
refund boom this holiday season
listeners get five dollars off plus free
shipping on harry's limited edition
holiday set when you go to harrys.com
leftovers the set comes with a weighted
handle three razor cartridges foaming
shave gel and a travel cover everything
you'll need for a smooth shave all
packaged and a handsome holiday gift box
do claim five bucks off your free uh
plus free shipping go to harry's dot com
slash leftovers
yes yes
and
stamps.com the man loves his mail sure
do
i love the mail
i love mail
yeah but you know what i don't like
that you know what i don't know i know
you want me to say it yeah you want me
to say it yeah i don't like going to the
post office
because it's there's lines and there's
crowds yeah are you going to park you
got to get out you got to carry [ __ ]
it's not vacant
don't like that
how will i how will i solve this problem
well there's a solution hassan and
thanks for asking stamps.com is the
solution if you're looking to skip trips
to the post office and dodge all the
hectic holiday shopping traffic why not
save time and money with stamps.com
you know what i'm saying whether you're
selling online or running an office or a
side hustle stamps.com could save you so
much time and money and stress during
the holiday you get access to all post
office and ups shipping services you
need without taking the trip and you get
discounts you can't find anywhere else
like up to 40 off usps rates and 76 off
ups
excuse me that's crazy the deals
the savings i'm sorry but i got to read
that again 76 off ups
i like that it's not
oh it's not 70 or 80 it's 76 percent all
day because they negotiated the best
possible rate yeah each percentage point
matters
clean numbers don't matter what matters
is savings going to post off instead of
using stamps.com is kind of like talking
taking the stairs instead of the
elevator just going up a couple of
floors what
it's a bit of a an analogy for me dude
yeah
okay you're talking the stairs you're
doing the elevator why go up a couple of
flights of stairs
when you could take when walking up when
you can use an elevator
yeah
calm yeah that was way more clear
that you're gonna save time and money
that was a good analogy
save time and money this holiday season
with stamps.com sign up with the promo
code leftovers first special offer that
includes a four week trial free postage
and a digital scale there's no long term
commitments or contracts just go to
stamps.com click on the microphone at
the top of the page and enter the code
leftovers thank you with peace and
love to our
lovely sponsors and now
drumroll please
it is time to finally settle the score
us a couple of white passing uh
[Music]
ethnically ambiguous i think i'm more
white than you what do you i just i
think i'm white like i'm super white you
know i but i guess white people don't
consider me white like which doesn't
consider me white that's what we found
out which was like well that's what i'm
saying
what because on a can a black person say
the n word on twitch
yeah
well what the [ __ ] then um well
first of all uh you can't call someone
else i i don't know if a black person
could call another black person the
n-word with a heart okay or okay i get
it uh i don't exactly know what the tos
uh you know how the tos would land on
that got it it is kind of funny though
because like things like this have
happened and white mostly white uh
chatters have endlessly pontificated on
like black content creators that they
normally don't even watch using the
n-word against other black content
creators that they also don't watch got
it so
it's just like
white redditors absolutely love
especially if you're like a debate lord
you [ __ ] love discussing the n-word
and you love discussing cracker
all this sort of stuff uh and uh you
know it was
that's the reason why it's such a big uh
deal here but i i personally thought i
was white so you're white i i i guess
i'm white in the same way like if you
asked the white supremacist they would
say no you're not white
you know
yeah depending on who you're talking to
yeah for sure but okay here we go
redneck that's kind of an iconic phrase
often frequently used i mean a redneck
so what are we what are we ranking
offensiveness oh offensiveness yeah
uh i mean that's the
let's bring this
no
i mean well if redneck's not in well
okay s i guess are we saying if s
are we doing this in a vacuum or is s
like the n word
equivalent
do you know what i'm saying dan what do
you think should we do this like in its
own vacuum
or should we say well the n word is
obviously s t or slur
right but i mean as far as white slurs
go i mean that's a good question should
it be because then they'd all be in the
eyes of twitch right exactly i think it
should be in a vacuum where we're we're
looking at it just in terms of
so you're saying redneck is f
i mean
redneck is one that has been adopted by
southerners they use it regularly on
themselves i feel like
yeah how do you know you're a redneck
yeah because you bought because you make
a the history of redneck also is really
interesting because it's the it's like
it links back to one of the largest like
labor uprisings in the country
um in in appalachia so it's a
it's more so a classis term
which we of course
don't get rednecks
yeah no no i i'm saying that like well
the thing is
you don't ever
you don't really have a term against
white people that like blanket applies
to all white people you know what i mean
you always have to add like
specific qualifiers even cracker
depending on what you're what you're uh
working with is like a
is a whip cracker right and redneck is
uh
it's still a classic one hillbilly these
are poor white people they're not like
there isn't really one that
yeah i mean it's all white
and
that appeals to all white people applies
all these are mostly about poor white
people i wonder if we could have one
like uh predator or something for uh the
harvey weinsteins of the world
well that's not white specific right
it's not okay so redneck i guess we're
gonna put it in like a maybe a d
like you redneck yeah yeah i mean
there's a lot of there's a lot of people
out there that are like i'm a redneck
and proud too
pretty well if we put this pretty blue
i'm afraid where everything's gonna be
down here well that might just be the
way it goes
i'm gonna put it up you say f i'm gonna
put it at d we're gonna compromise a
little bit
okay red i mean i would not be offended
by calling a redneck at all i love i
love rednecks let's put it to f
a fish belly
i don't know what this is a fish belly
you want to give us some intel on this
ian
this was a dance emission actually
leonard is ian and dan are white
whisperers
they they yeah they have putters
together these
these are some deep cuts some of these
um
we're too crackery that we had to go to
we had to go to end yeah
yeah
i feel like sam's a real whitey uh ian
maybe she can help us uh well
again i was the one that submitted fish
belly and um yeah by the way is whitey
in here oh yeah it is good yeah white of
course of course uh yeah that again
that's it's kind of just a deep cut i
don't think people even really what does
it i guess that would be it's like a
belly i'm like a beer belly uh right
well i think it's in reference to uh the
belly of a fish being pale
all right that's an f yeah yeah fish
belly
your damn fishbowl i feel like a lot of
this is just like [ __ ] that white people
came up with uh for other white people
totally i mean you know what i mean
face i mean
that one i like that yeah pale face it's
a good one
i don't know what that i use that and
this use that in the word [ __ ]
you [ __ ] pale face [ __ ] i
mean yeah okay pale face you pale i mean
i've never heard it i don't think it's
offensive
a lot of these we're teaching people
this is the educational hour here are
some new ways to to you know uh oppress
white people yeah pale face i mean again
i i think that's an f i'm just being
honest
hog
so hog is my favorite i use it all the
time uh but i feel like it's not even
it's not even just white people like you
know you can you can it's mostly white
people but hog just means like
conservative
so
just a hog that's a f2 this is gonna
a lot of this is gonna be in the f
category i feel like right here now
we're getting now we're heating up
cracker
i mean you know what my thing is
we can't put this as an f it has some
context it has some history yeah of uh
of you know bit of usage cracker i mean
that's got to be at least a d right
okay i mean if you say so
i think you i guess
i guess it's higher yeah it's definitely
hotter than like
fish
belly
yeah it's it's a little bit higher than
that for sure yeah cracker it has the
capacity for like people to be
legitimately offended uh by it even if
they're in the margins you know what i
mean like crackers someone could be like
oh well that's really [ __ ] mean that
hurts my feelings like i can see that i
think that should be a c a cracker okay
it has some it has some potential
okay and then you've got hillbilly which
is you know a classic another classic
you hillbilly i don't think it's
offensive though
you're damned
it just still means like poor white
person uh uneducated poor white person
right
i guess
yeah is it do people
we need a white person yeah we need like
a sam or ian yeah and not like us not
like us we need like
ian you put you did ian tell us what
this [ __ ] means
well you know what hillbilly means it's
a hillbilly yeah no no i know but like i
need to judge the severity of this by
like staring at the face of a wasp man
who is like this is this is it you know
what i mean i mean ian you're a damn
hillbilly ian is the waspiest one here
ian are you happy
the same guy right here boom boom boom
yeah no even then i'm not buying it
benjamin franklin would want only one of
you in the country right yeah and that's
ian he would want ian in there none of
that are you half english and then half
what what's the other half ian well if
i'm english then hillbilly wouldn't
apply to me right are there hillbilly
english people yes oh yeah i mean when
you're yeah when you live you're not
english anymore
yeah you know
he's first generation though look at him
running away from the slur by the way
that means it's more i am starting to
panic so it might be a b yeah a
hillbilly
what's your other happy in
just english in america okay
so you're deluded a little bit your why
purity is that question who knows what's
in that american half
okay well hillbilly is not doing much um
i'll put it at a d maybe just because i
think it's actually a word
all of these by the way
i feel like if you're a white person and
i did see this in the chat because i am
reading chat i'm getting my chat right
now let me open chat because i'm not
reading chat should i make you a mod so
you can ban people oh that'd be awesome
yeah
but i'm already i'm daniel on here so oh
you got my power there yeah go for it so
uh people were saying like a lot of
these words would hurt me uh hurt my
feelings uh from a class point of view
like it would just like make fun of me
for being poor
rather than make me feel bad because i'm
white that's what that's true yeah and
that's true that is literally what this
is i guess yeah i mean but but okay
well like hillbilly to me hillbilly's
probably around the same as cracker i
guess all right yeah hillbilly i've i
actually i disagree i think cracker
should be drf personally i think
really i do
yeah
all right let's move on hick i mean
hicks pretty good
right you hick
you damn hick
not really i mean like a lot of these
have like uh
uh
like
personal adoptions you know what i mean
like i feel like i can see a white
person be like yeah i'm a hick whatever
you know what i mean i'm a hit but i
can't go for cracker for example i'm a
cracker that's true but i can't see it
for hillbilly i can see it for hick
i'm gonna go with this identity yeah
because white people generally wouldn't
call it themselves cracker which maybe
makes it worse
that's a good observation so we're going
to move hick down to a d i'm a hick so
what
let's go down to the pig farm now shoot
off some guns
come on now
yeah honky
i don't even like
i want to know the etymology of these
words you know i mean i don't honky
sounds bad it definitely does really you
don't think it sounds bad
i think let's see what does honky cuz
honky is like closest to
people wait what i mean oh a derogatory
term used by black people for white
people or white people collectively
honky
yeah
it's a
20th century term
or immigrant from central or eastern
europe
only dates back to 1946 from bow honk
apparently hmm
so there you go exactly honky is a 1971
movie based on an inter
interracial relationship as well
hockey talk is also a 1974 western film
yeah
honky tonk man i mean conch the thing is
if somebody called me a honky i would
probably just laugh yeah no no no i mean
all of these are i think cracker i think
i'm putting her honky cracker would be
oh you think hockey's like cracker at
least i would know what they're saying
if someone's like called me a honky i'd
be like
what the [ __ ] i mean every single one of
these is laughable i'm just i'm trying
to do the best with what i've got here
well this is only exposing that you and
i are not pure like we are not pure
white
the nazis on twitter were right to tell
me that i was not asking but i always
you know
i'm like white but nobody wants to
nobody wants me as part of their group
i feel the same way yeah
uh
well okay if you think i don't know
anything then you tell me this one's not
a racist a [ __ ] skin comb skin is
hilarious
i had never heard that one before that's
awesome what the [ __ ] is comes i mean a
lot of these are new like and i know
like there's some on here that are not
on here i i can't see at least like mayo
monkey uh vanilla gorilla
like these are
these are words that like black twitter
has come up with to utilize like all of
the racist [ __ ] that white people have
said about black people they flipped it
and basically like tied it back to
whiteness
so they're too new for people to like
recognize and get upset at and i think
come skin is another one of those come
skin is so vulgar but i mean again if
somebody said come skin i would just be
flabbergasted i mean i would be amused
and
come
just like what yeah so i don't know come
skin is pretty funny
um
you know i mean if you're saying that
it's just funny is that that must be
someone who's really pale though because
i feel like we're not compskin dude i'm
pale as [ __ ] i don't know what you're
talking about no but like there's whiter
people like real whitey whitey's
yeah i don't know i don't think you're a
cumskin bro
okay well oh bummer yeah
i'm gonna put come skim with cracker i
guess because
okay i guess the intention there is to
offend okay we got peckerwood coming up
yeah peckerwood and again is that a
white slur i feel like it's just oh yeah
no it definitely is it is isn't it like
uh
peckerwood a white person especially a
poor one see like it's actually that one
is
i think that is actually in the adl uh
database i think
oh like that came up yeah the word
pecker would have originated as an
african-american slang term for
woodpecker in the 19 or in the 1800s but
by the early 1900s began to be applied
as a racial epithet against whites with
a meaning similar to the term white
trash once again not just specifically
white but like also white trash or
glasses it has to be tied with something
else that's right interesting yeah yeah
pecker they're all basically like you
said
um
based on clap yeah because whiteness is
a is a concept that was created
around purity racial purity and also it
means it's a concept of dominance so
like having a term against
white people as a whole without like
adding any sort of modifiers onto it is
just going to always fall short it
doesn't mean it it doesn't mean anything
it's no fun yeah it's like okay yeah and
even when you add additional modifiers
it still doesn't uh it still doesn't hit
as hard as any other [ __ ] term but
but that is something that you have to
add on that's why a lot of these slurs
are actually poor white person
uneducated white person white trash like
right that's
that's what i always say is like you
have to drive yeah you get why people
are oppressed by virtue of class
but not by virtue of simply being white
so how about uh here's actually another
important wrinkle that i just discovered
is that apparently pecker was commonly
applied to white prisoners in general
yeah and
there were peckerwood gangs that kind of
came out of that and that is actually
what evolved into the aryan brotherhood
yeah it's the racist prison game that
brotherhood are a bunch are the pecker
original peckers
yeah
so maybe that one does have a little bit
of weight you know okay so call it next
white supremacist you may call him a
peckerwood yeah i always thought it was
a penis joke i thought it was just
calling him they said they had a little
weenie
no no no no
i've i've heard that one before it's
definitely that would be like a racist
white person that's poor so we're going
to put it at c because of the white
supremacy thing or do you think maybe
i mean yeah sounds like it's got a
little little weight to it right yeah
there's like there's like white people
with like if you see a white person with
a pecker with tattoo it means they're
probably in a prison gang like they were
in a racist prison gang
wow yeah there's like there's images of
this thing
pecker woods i didn't know that
yeah white trash that's a good one
white trash is a good one but again
class
yeah
white trash again uh poor uneducated
white person let's put that in c
you know
then here's a real good one okay
colonizer
that's a tick-tock one
people love saying why people are
colonizers
that's an interesting one it's so funny
because like so if somebody called me a
colonizer i might get defensive you know
they'd be like i don't you know what the
[ __ ] you saying to me calling i didn't
call nice [ __ ]
i wasn't even here during the
colonization it's funny when it's like
launched towards like irish people too
it's just like it it's a catch-all term
i think it's funny it's too new i feel
like for its application to be here i
feel like it would really offend some
people though
like people who are like real patriots i
ain't colonized [ __ ]
i guess yeah i feel like this could
offend some people in terms of i
wouldn't even maybe put that beat here
because i feel like if you start running
around calling white people colonizers
you will offend people
i could see that especially because like
i mean we are all beneficiaries of
american colonization american
imperialism that's just that's a real
true thing um but even
even those who have been historically
colonized that have lived here for
multiple generations also fall under
that category so it's like a it's a
unique situation
what do you think about colonizer you
agree with that dan i feel like that's a
pretty good one
more offensive than cracker though
yeah yeah
i do think so but what do you think no
shot no
in colonizer because the slur itself is
like sort of
referring to a specific history it seems
less slurry to me you know what i mean
like i'm telling you though if you want
to go offend someone i feel like calling
people colonizer might be the best way
yeah
because cracker but i don't know if that
really strikes
like you said anything it kind of
strikes at their uh patriotic uh side
more than if you like just okay identity
side here's what we need to do imagine
you're talking to tucker carlson how
offended would he be if you called him
one of these words i think that's a good
mental practice oh if you called he
wanted to right he would cry piss and
[ __ ] his pants on all of them though i
think call the police immediately yeah
he actually would [ __ ] belly he'd be
like esteer yeah he'll face esteer
many people are calling me a colonizer
many people are way worse than the n
word which you should be able to say
many people have been calling me fish
belly i think that's super offensive and
don't we care about white people anymore
in this country
colonizer i think he would be most
pissed by colonizer all right we got to
move on you guys like it in beer should
i or should i move it down
i don't i i have no feeling on colonizer
because like we are colonizers you know
what i mean like we are that's what you
know
it's sort of you're too woke bro you've
got to think about tucker what tucker
would feel i mean i think tucker would
just get mad regardless yeah exactly
that's so that's too high or too large
all right so you guys think it should
move down where do you want it
it's a weird one i see that the chat is
very torn on this one too i think
colonizer is a great one i think you all
are tripping i've seen some chat get a
little defensive
too
like people are getting mad about it
yeah i've seen a couple so
yeah there's there's people who are like
saying it's not a big deal but then
there's a lot of people who are saying
like no this is the worst thing this is
the worst thing that i've seen so far
here let's do a vote can you put it to a
vote dan
like a poll yeah and do like is it yeah
yeah well i think you know what okay
here here's a here's a qualifier do you
like f i think colonizer is worse than
these other ones because well there's an
element of truth to it okay so that
that's good that that makes it worse
powerful yeah right and also
you don't have to literally be like a
racist person to be called a colonizer
and i think that's why it's like an
closest to a catch-all term it's very
automatically and i think a lot of
people would get very defensive too yeah
it brings up a lot it brings up a lot i
like colonizer for white slur i can i
can see that i like it
not even in america i mean white people
are traditionally colonizers so you can
even take that all the way back to the
english empire oh yeah and and and hit
them hard all the way back
so i
youtube poll limits you to four options
yeah so do f
but would you ban someone for calling a
white person a colonizer an a ridiculous
obviously right of course not yeah okay
because again the power is in the hands
of the colonizers it would be insane
you're not like dehumanizing them for
you colonizer twitch yeah no of course
so i'll do i'll do s b c f to kind of
run the the gamut here or maybe s people
vote s i'm afraid if we include s i'm
just it's not s here it might be
actually so a b c f a b c f yeah okay
like i my background is from an
imperialist power i'm turkish so like
100
we 100
did
not uh colonialism but imperialism like
the ottoman empire absolutely engaged in
that so you know slavery all the
all the fun stuff that comes along with
that we are okay the wings are coming in
guys
all right it looks like b has an early
lead b is dominant i see that
okay well it's shaking a little bit get
your votes in guys
get your votes in
we like in b
6 000 votes in it looks like a it looks
like a strong b result there
yeah
i mean there's a bit of a spread okay so
we have our new champion of white slurs
colonizer okay
okay this is a good i'm just going to
bring out the good ones because like
snow possum i mean that's great that
all right those are so creative and
funny that they sleep awesome f yeah
yeah it's just funny because it's like i
feel like ones that uh refer to the
color of your skin are pretty funny
because it it doesn't even like the ones
that try to target just a quality of
whiteness as a catch-all term
are somehow less severe than like a
direct action associated with whiteness
because it's just like they're saying
you have pale skin and historically
as a consequence of both uh colonialism
and also colonization and also on top of
that even like a a
classist uh
reasoning for it in like asian uh
cultures and asian countries uh saying
that you have pale skin
is it just doesn't hit as hard do you
see what i'm saying well
even though that is quite literally
the one way that you can target racially
a white person well in a lot of
southeastern countries correct me if i'm
wrong they like bleach their skin or
yeah or to make there's two different
reasons for that one is because of
obviously imperialism and and
colonization
but also it it is uh even before that it
predates it in like china for example uh
it has been a part of chinese culture as
a consequence of classist
uh attitudes the fairer your skin
uh the the further removed you are from
the field uh right sure like the
marlboro uh man they tried to like mimic
that exact same cowboy in china
originally with like a darker skinned
chinese man smoking a cigarette like
he's rugged and it actually hurt their
sails because everyone was like what the
[ __ ] we don't want this peasant uh
telling us to smoke a cigarette
because fair skin is still associated
with like aristocracy and that
actually has everything to do with
classism again and not necessarily uh
you know colonialism okay so snow possum
mayo i think is f i mean what the [ __ ]
uh i'm just getting rid of the of the
obvious ones pink dick i mean
pink dick
that one i think actually came from
bobby lee
pink pink dick yeah
he calls uh his producer george uh pink
dick all the time this is why depression
uh white people is gonna be f i'm sorry
block twitter
white people
why people yeah that one is [ __ ]
annoying i i don't like that one and i
don't like yt
like instead of saying whitey like black
twitter will write like y and t
as a substitute for whitey and it's just
like it just looks
it's lame i guess yeah white people it's
just it doesn't have like a
oomph to it you know what i mean
yukubian i'm sorry again this a little
bit i love i love you [ __ ] like deep
anime lore i don't know that's like a
[ __ ] oh dude i'll show you some
videos after this it is straight up
there is an anime a yokubian oh yeah
there is an anime uh
yeah there's like a nation of islam
anime about the oranges or the the
origins of like
uh white people uh
being created i guess it is offensive
but i don't think anyone knows what it
means i guess yukubian it's like white
gay men but whatever yeah we're kind of
we're kind of [ __ ] it up for for a
lot of people including myself i love
using that term regularly
yeah are you should i move it up
no no no just let's keep it after here
really move it up maybe i should move
no don't do that don't do that no no no
no
you're taking away all the fun it's too
deep laura right it does nothing yeah
okay so here we've got some really good
ones milk demon again
i'm gonna put that f sorry okay now
we're gonna get to the really good ones
white devil
white devil do you think it's a bee i'm
just putting it there as a place holder
just so we can debate it okay you're i'm
just putting it here so we can see
what's what's up next white devil i like
white devil
i
not only do i think it's funny
um but it's also
true
yeah it's true i mean white people are
the devil generally right wow you are so
raised against whites dude
i'm self-hating they're truly oppressed
people people ian and dan do you guys
feel do you guys feel uh you know host
white devil
is uh we gotta we gotta refer to them
dude we gotta let the whites talk here
i'm trying but they're they're keeping
their the mums of the word over here
they're afraid of getting bigger yeah um
ian over there is the white he's the
white what's going on are you guys
worried you're betraying your race or
[Laughter]
i mean i think white devil is good i
mean if somebody called me a white devil
i would be taking it back because it's
like it's so
it's just like what i mean
that one would tickle me i mean it's
just
it's like
it's a lot it's a lot the white devil
there's a lot of really good ones that
are not on here like i said vanilla
gorilla is another one snow roach i mean
those are f those are uh there's uh the
children of the chalk
no purpose no purpose flower
no purple the [ __ ] is that it's just
like i'm just shouts out the 39 death a
friend of mine uh they were like going
through some of their favorite uh white
slurs
what the [ __ ] does that mean though a
flower a flower it's just they'd stain
white people have no purpose
flowers white
oh yeah play on all-purpose flour
instead it's no purpose flour yeah
flour's white
sorry shout out to your friend but yeah
i think it's clever that's pretty good i
think children of the chalk is great
well i like white devil i mean
ian if i just came up to you every day
and i was like what's up white devil i
mean that's pretty offensive
uh if you did that every day
repetitively i would call you in the
evening and say hey white devil just a
reminder you're a colonizer bye
okay but that's that's the repetition is
annoying at that point you know what i
mean all right yuko okay tucker carlson
you go on a show and you call him a
white devil his head explodes for sure
uh yeah his head does explode on that
one like that'd be so
that tucker of all these probably would
be most offended by a white devil i feel
like he would have an aneurysm on the
spot yeah his nose would start bleeding
like
that'd be so sick so i liking it anyone
got any opinion here i need some help on
this one i i don't i don't find it
offensive at all but yeah well you're
not even pure so
who are you
fair enough i
yeah i think it's a good placement
you think it's up there and b yeah i
think so okay i do oh wait this is this
is a safe space is any of this actually
uh impact dude do you do you ever do you
feel like you would be offended by any
of this me no zack's jewish i'm a jew
i'm full jew yeah he doesn't know he's
[ __ ]
what about ian
i mean i think i'd make a recovery with
most of these ian put this together
well you're making him do emotionally
you're hanging out his idea i mean
not that blaming it on the white guy
not that this would even not that this
one really even gets to me either but it
having grown up in los angeles at a
school that was pr predominantly uh you
know latino uh students um
there was a lot of like jokingly using
terms like whitey and cracker but it it
genuinely
was
it didn't have the same impact or oomph
um i'd say the most common one i
probably got called growing up is just
white boy yeah
i got that a lot yeah just being a white
boy that should be on here and another
one but that that offends you and
another one for lately i mean you say
not really that makes me think d
well i mean it's somebody it's it's kind
of like what hassam was saying at the
beginning it's like
when you're
somebody's calling you
names aggressively you know it it hurts
your matters in a way but yeah i don't
think it you know the racial component
is just not there for uh a white kid
growing up i agree you know what you
know what it sucks though you know what
sucks though is someone who has been
called a lot of these words especially
by you know fandoms on the internet the
only part of it that sucks is that like
the automatic qualifier that like even
despite the fact that you yourself are
not racist in any capacity whatsoever
and you're anti-racist and and all this
stuff
that um the automatic assumption is that
you are racist so i do identify with
that i do understand uh why white people
get upset at it like i do understand why
whenever someone's like oh shut up white
boy you're like well that's kind of
sucks like yeah you know because um i i
do understand it not to the same degree
of like experiencing it personally
that'll something that's something that
i'll never understand
but the inverse of that is true as well
where um i recognize where that person
is coming from from from experiencing uh
racism so much uh both through these
systems uh and reinforced through all of
our uh you know all of our
cultural analysis all throughout media
and [ __ ] like that so
i i do get it one thing i wanted to
mention that is not on this list that
definitely should have been on this list
i think it's gringo hmm
there's a lot of gringos
because you're already editing it i
don't think can i reload the list
but then it'll [ __ ] up like all of our
people yeah [ __ ] that oh it will yeah so
i don't i would probably go as an f to
be honest i think so been in mexico my
parents live there they don't use the
word in a derogatory way it just means
like like it's like a white kid
which also isn't on this list but like
that is another yeah yankee
turk turks used to say go home yankee to
americans
that's so weird that they use that
because they're american specific right
not necessarily what kind of confederate
used as like us
yeah
i mean yeah but it i think is still like
internationally it's considered like in
certain places considered to be like
anti-white i guess or anti-american but
anti-white for the most part i don't
think yankee is a as a f and i think
green goes an f too
so gringo the reason why i mention it is
because like places where it's used
gringo
plays where it's used usually why people
are in the minority yeah and from what i
understand uh like from
because i've been pulling all of my
white friends and i have a lot of them i
myself am white as well but i want to
understand it a little bit better and
that's the one that especially uh white
friends of mine that have worked with
like uh latin american co-workers and
like kitchens and [ __ ] like that that's
the one where they were like that's it
that's the one that actually does uh
upset me and they call them like a pinch
of green i think i think it depends how
you say it but like
it's the other one oh yeah yeah
i think people are just saying gringo
just means white american it isn't yeah
i think it really depends how they say
it you know yeah because you can say it
like you [ __ ] gringo right i mean
mexico they pretty much exclusively
called me though yeah but it was
actually a positive two like this right
it's a yeah again
because white supremacy and and call in
you know post-cano post-colonial
countries there's a lot of white
mexicans and or or white passing
mexicans so widow from what i understand
is actually seen as like a term of
positivity if if being used against
other mexicans from what i'm pulling
here the mexicans in the chat are saying
gringo is not
is not offensive
yeah and a lot of people saying widow is
endearing
oh really it really just apparently
other people are saying the opposite so
yeah i mean i i guess it just kind of it
just for me it's an advantage
i'm putting i'm gonna put white double c
okay then the also oh i mean the instant
s is obviously karen
that one's actually that one
that one has the history of oppression
and yeah
white women are [ __ ] terrified
okay of going to a cvs and calling the
manager
because they're gonna get called karen
and it's gonna be filmed and all of a
sudden they're [ __ ] famous okay you
are denying white women
of a god-given constitutionally
protected right that america has
afforded them which is to be able to
call the [ __ ] manager
yeah it's crazy i heard someone say
about karen they say karen is the oh i
think it was the quartering actually he
goes okay all these people are just
following around white women everywhere
they go recording them everywhere they
go just hoping they slip up so they can
call them karen yeah i was like what the
[ __ ] no quartering that's a self-report
you're following women around you
[ __ ] creeper that's true so karen's
asked here obviously uh that what the
white women have never recovered since
karen became a thing and then whitey
uh let's just as an interest moving on
let's put that as c
okay all right there you have it guys
so colonizer i think turns out to be the
most offensive
potentially
thing to call a white person so the more
you know i don't think any of these
deserve i don't think any of these are
bandworthy but i do understand that both
of them are bandworthy but i do
understand the difficult predicament
that uh you know
twitch uh gets faced with when there's a
lot of backlash because like they can't
be
they can't be taking a hard line
sorry to cut you off they
they can't be taking a hard-line stance
on like yeah you can be uh racist
towards white people because like that's
not going to look good and plus on top
of that as like large content creators
uh
someone like myself i i recognize that
like if i was just [ __ ] constantly
like you should be able to say it you
should be able to say it that's a little
bit different than me saying it's not
bandworthy you know what i mean because
my argument is like yeah don't hurt
people's feelings if they don't deserve
it right because you know i i do like
making jokes i do sometimes uh end up
making harm like jokes that hurt
people's feelings for sure as i was
describing to you before comedy is about
punching you can either punch up you can
punch down in some unique instances you
can punch forward but there's always a
punch and the people that cry about you
know white identity politics or the
people that like say you can't do this
are trying to eliminate
another way that we could just make
jokes it's if it's the oppressor
category you should be able to make
jokes about that why are you taking this
away i as a white person would be able
to still i would like to still make you
know white people jokes
it's like
it's just so
it's always weird too because there's
always the people who are like what i
can't be racist like you're [ __ ]
comedy that [ __ ] then cry about this
[ __ ]
it's annoying exactly
listen
what do you think about women who are
born karen i mean do we need to worry
about them or are they just casualties
of war yeah
they're they just can't
just can't do anything about it
yeah but ultimately i get it you know it
can be offensive but at the end of the
day that i thought you meant like people
that are born to call the manager i
didn't even think that there are women
there are people who you know their name
predates the karen phenomenon yeah
that's true i mean
i guess you can always change your name
i mean
wow yeah look there's always casualties
in war i mean it's friendly fire
and uh
that's just there's a certain amount of
friendly fire that happens in every war
and ripped to all cairns everywhere
by the way you know there ain't no new
white babies being called karen
i wonder if it dropped off i think i
actually saw that it was like the
biggest drop-off ever
no new cameras boy
like barbara
barbara could be the new camera what do
we got there's like there's a lot of
like white women names that
debra have been taken out of yeah taken
out of commission bring back deborah's
barbara's uh eileen give me a good one
eileen is good too what are what are
some like meredith
meredith is a good one it's like i want
to i want to know like there's certain
names that white women are named that
you're like okay that's like a person
that was born in 1958 yeah no no there's
a there's a person born before like when
jim crow laws were still in effect you
know what i mean uh i mean deborah karen
bethel bethelink bethany
bethany is that even apple ethel and
bethany yeah ethel sam you got one for
us you're leaning in damn someone said
she's actually here letting me know um
that amaranth is here susan and uh
you hear that
yeah ethan yeah amaranth is here so
we're gonna move on to our next segment
um so here's what we're gonna do next so
i hope you guys enjoyed this uh
colonizer tier list
i feel like we made a lot of progress
here today
we solved racism against white people
yeah
up next we've got uh
we're bringing out amaranth to play
white people bingo
and as you know amaranth famous hot tub
streamer
we are going to be getting in a hot tub
but wait we have a special surprise so
stay tuned guys we gotta go get set that
up so we'll be back in like five minutes
all right i gotta pee real bad
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right here we are on the set of what
was once this the fountain of
uh friends
we have reappropriated it we are now on
the show crackers
is wild how much money
oh yeah
yeah we're clapping for that okay yeah
okay
is is wild how much money ethan has been
spending on all of this the the five
percent goes such a long way out here we
literally got the same fountain like
this is where we're at yeah we're at
universal we're on the lot right now
yeah we transported quickly and uh we're
on matt leblanc
what's good
it's crazy so we're joined by amaranth
uh she is the whitest person i know
so what's your origin
uh i'm half italian also the other half
is english irish and a little bit of a
cherokee actually oh the cherokee that
causes problems that's that's straight
up that is
the most white american thing it is i'm
basically immigration in america how
much cherokee you got
uh i think like an eighth
oh that's a big that's a good amount
yeah you could probably if when you were
a kid in school you could probably even
do like the native american studies with
that
you got more than elizabeth warren my
great-grandmother had those really long
traditional white braids she looked just
like
she was out of like a fairy tale she was
so cool
do you mind if we call you pocahontas or
oh my god i mean if you won't get banned
you can call me whatever you want wait
was that a bannable effect yes
really i think that's more i mean
anything that trump has done is a good
good measure to just not don't yeah
don't grab me by the by oh no no no no
no no no of course not that closer okay
there we go oh i thought you were coming
in i thought you were coming in with the
hoodie like you need to cover her up
yeah well so what what we're here today
is obviously i didn't know you were a
white authority so this is good this
will be hell yeah so what we're doing
today is we're obviously wanted to um
did something happen we lost the feed or
is that just on our end dan
everything's fine on the stream right
because we lost the preview monitor oh
yes everything is okay so what we're
doing is a hot tub
stream which i think are you the pioneer
of the hot tub stream no but i will take
credit for it so yes respect you're an
early adopter oh yeah
there we go white people behavior right
there
that should be on the so yeah like that
so we're doing a bingo card is there
claiming credit for the being the first
when they aren't is that should be
honest no but but unironically um saying
that you have a percentage of native
american is one of the ones on no way
that's not really well they're
randomized so i don't know if it's on
yours but that is one of the categories
for white bingo all right so well
instead of water obviously we have a
special ingredient here to fill the hot
tub with so guys go ahead let's fill the
hot tub bro we should have straight up
gotten sponsor for this
a cracker sponsor yeah yeah oh nabisco
here can you do that here let's pick up
the dogs hold on a b where the
capitalist what's going on right now
dude
he's looking i wish man i'm not that
good of a capitalist so what we have
here is gallons how big of a gallon tub
is this we're talking
yeah
so got you can just go ahead and dump
my man's got that he's got that workout
body going
[Laughter]
he's like oh wow how easily she picked
it up all right you really reconsider
your upper body strength for this fight
all right so go ahead we have got a
a whoa whoa whoa you can't see it you
can't see it do it on cam
go behind me if you can oh shredder are
you interested in those crackers
we have we have ritz crackers
[Music]
not meat too picky
there we go
we can't see it we can't see it come on
get
alfredo's not a fan of the pouring oh my
god
i think it's fine you can let him go
yeah watch out you alfredo don't pee
all right feet are about to get wet in
the fountain there you go you can just
get it all over me don't be shy now
we're in a hot tub damn it they're
trying to get getting the mood here this
is definitely going in my ass crack
go ahead baby don't be shy
oh yeah baby
what a good time karissi
yum yum yum
all right we're not done yet
is there a trash somewhere
you can just throw it
aside and then we have of course the uh
[Music]
the 20 gallon tub here here we go this
is the big one
just go in front of the camera then
yeah
okay
there it is
there it is
okay here maybe pick the doggies
let me out you off
alfredo sorry
chaos with the dog they're like no they
got treats there's pillows in here and
[ __ ] all right come on let it rain
this is the cracker special now don't be
shy
oh
yeah don't be shy now
oh my goodness i'm buried in it
can you get a shot from above so people
can see what we're working with here
[Music]
hello
yeah all right so here we are oh my
goodness shredder's like like fresh snow
shredder is stomped like leaves
crackers here let me take a pile of
leaves oh shredder
you're so cute i'm almost certain i
haven't seen the bingo points yet but
what ethan is engaging in right now is
absolutely a bingo you got it right the
dog lick your face nailed it dog lick
your face that extremely people [ __ ]
that is that is on the car true you you
got it
do you not let that do you guys let dog
oh i 100 percent i do
yeah and not even like my own dog i'll
lick i'll i'll [ __ ] kiss strangers
dogs in the mouth oh sure i don't give a
[ __ ]
let me take this pillow
oasis here there you go immediately yes
there you go please thank you i love
that
we love that it's a little it's a little
jerky let me show that shot again maybe
[Music]
shaky hands doctor av
cheers everybody
[Applause]
really good you know this slabs
we've had buckets of them around the
office since yesterday and we've all
been
dipping into those crackers like just a
free a free uh covered that's how you
know when it's good we're all boosted
that's how you know it's good though you
can hit it raw like you don't need like
extra i mean cheese would be improvement
can we get somebody's in here yeah we
got we'll get some cheese
some cheese we have cheese
oh yeah yeah
please bring some cheese
he's like no i'm not [ __ ] with that
so how's everyone feeling good you're
here for the
oh that yeah my phone number's on their
caller let's not do that again for the
20th time
so how are you feeling about the cracker
discourse you've joined us here today on
a auspicious day i actually expected
more crackers won't lie it's a little
that's a lot of crackers i thought we
were going to be like up to here and
crackers
like not even be able to move
but you know you're right i'll take it
the budget uh
we ran out of budget for crackers i'll
be honest how much did we spend on
crackers dan i mean i think it was like
a hundred bucks or something honestly
the biggest limiter was the size of the
car because that was that was all sam
could fit in yeah it wasn't a money
issue it was a logistics issue but if i
had your whole posse then maybe i could
have pulled up this damn
thing with the whole cracker that's all
right extravagant okay next time next
time next time someone gets banned for
you know slurring we'll do it okay well
let's play bingo shall we yeah so also
for people out in the audience um i've
created
a uh an album an imgur album i'm gonna
pin it in the chat right now so you can
play it along at home you can play along
at home there's there's about 20
different cards in there just pick one
at random um
you know none are better than any other
but
whichever one appeals to you here i'm
going to pin it right now we gotta get
us we have needed consistent shot
overhead guys amaranth did you think
this was what we were gonna be doing
when i said we're gonna do a hot dog
stream uh you know it's not what it
quite what i had in mind but i will take
it because
crackers are delicious and we love them
oh look at this show show what you've
crafted here a perfect
cracker experience it's a very white
person meal
definitely
absolutely
with some salami
some cheese
all right where did the bingo cards go
baby you ran off with those oh he's
right here hold up
so let's let's uh here let's pass these
out each card is unique and different
just like every white person
we're all beautiful snowflakes that's
right that's right
thank you so much hassan thank you okay
now
should i read what's on here
let's read what our options are well
i think it's better to wait we're gonna
because we're gonna read them all off um
as we as we go along
all right
is the audience playing too the audience
is playing along i've i've shared that
is there prizes for who gets bingo in
the audience
if they screenshot and show on discord
or something the winner gets a new pair
of
alligator
skinned boots they get a box of ritz
crackers signed
[Applause]
just take some from the pool and shove
it back in the box and perfect ship it
out to you that'd be worth more yeah
that's probably true
okay so
this is like a bath water situation do
you think people would buy your
sat on ritz cracker crackers they
probably would start an ebay auction
i wouldn't i would let you just give me
like you know a percentage and no it's
all you i mean you you're free to take a
jar of rich crackers that amaranth is
sat on maybe fart on them fart on would
you fart on crackers and sell it i mean
if that makes the value go up i'll do
anything to him
i wouldn't say so i would definitely
what if we all fart on that would make
the value go down i feel like you're
diluting the fart pool we just want one
good pure white hard to tell who's far
to see at that point why'd you
as soon as i lay back you're like i know
i can't decide if i want to be leaning
back in the pool it's real comfy like
when you when you get down it is better
like that
i don't know it's also interesting
because like when i'm holding a
microphone
i'm not sure if it's better yeah
you stand up
well when all three of us lean it it
does something
yeah what are we gonna say
wow
well you don't have to sit like that you
can just put your head up a little bit
my personality's too heavy right the
momentum you know momentum just knocks
me back there's a lot of weight there is
what were you saying uh essen
what i was saying was shredder's like
look at these white [ __ ] people when
i when i have like
when i have a microphone in my hand my
oh i'm sinking
my vibe changes like i'm i feel like i'm
doing stand-up comedy right now you know
like hey what's going on everybody is
that good or bad no it's good oh it is
good i think so i think i'm cooler when
i'm holding a microphone like this i
feel that maybe that's why noah miller
does his twitch streams like this um
is that live so you can show i think you
should okay good
awesome all right let's play the damn
game all right let's go so i've entered
all uh there's there's 51 uh
squares total and i've entered them all
into a randomizer which i am clicking
right now um
and here we go
you guys are both
more health conscious than me
i mean i'm eating i'm gonna clear i'm
gonna clear this [ __ ] i mean the
crackers are bad enough as it is that's
not good for your diet is it no
i hadn't i had i had two crackers i
think i'm good yeah you're good you're
gonna need more than just contributing
two crackers i wouldn't give them the
salami okay yeah make sure don't eat
that then
all right here we go all right the first
one first right people bingo play along
at home here we go all right
uh if you have
a bowl of marbles on a table somewhere
in your house
a bowl of wait what do i say
yes a bowl of marbles now i'm confused
that's on my list but i don't have a
bowl of mine oh well then unfortunately
you are not white you have to have it
together
and you have to also indeed do that yeah
oh i [ __ ] up i already crossed it i
don't have a bowl of marbles you don't
have a bowl of marble you have a bowl of
no i don't have a bowl of marbles okay
i'm going to put a [ __ ] that's more
of a boomer old lady thing well i was
about to say if the house that you grew
up in had a bowl of marbles on the table
um no i think that that would qualify as
well wow okay well dan are you
self-reporting have you experienced i
feel like marbles i feel like my mom
might have had a jar of marbles at some
point oh i feel like i've seen this okay
crystal mommy [ __ ] before like 1958 yeah
i'm seeing in the chat quite a few
people saying that uh my mom has that
yep i have that yep okay okay well not
us
all right so next number two
um
have you do you use the words buddy or
pal on a semi-regular basis
i don't think so call people buddy or
pound you guys ever hear me say buddy
um
do you call your son buddy maybe what's
up buddy oh you call your dogs buddy i
feel like maybe yeah oh you've
definitely called the dogs buddy that
doesn't count though you get no there's
like
buddy i feel like is a is is a power
word that white people use like all
right all right buddy all right pal oh
that's true that can be like but your
dog's gonna be like what's up buddy yeah
you know like that's white though yeah
well it's not even on my card so what
the hell it's on my card but i don't say
that ah
unfortunate this is like
there's a one-eighth cherokee stopping
you well we can we can slam through
these all right um
need a high spf sunscreen extra high
some screen
burns easily i definitely do use
sunscreen oh yeah i don't see it oh yeah
i'm crossing that one i didn't get that
one um i have it and i'm and i need it
oh i never use it okay i got it i'm on
the board
but i don't use it but i still need it
you don't use it in my old age i i i
i don't [ __ ] around man i put on that
sunscreen lather up
you [ __ ] around with sunscreen i do but
it's not on my board yeah i don't i
don't go out in the sun without it
you're [ __ ] i'm gonna beat you
okay um have you been hit on by a cousin
at any point
okay hit on by a cousin yep
uh not me you can't say that i have no
damn okay enough crowd out here there
were there was a few back stage i
believe or at least yesterday that said
that they were gonna right here too you
could get on by your cousin oh yeah tell
me about it
she tried to uh
have her weight with me
really oh my gosh first cousin first
cousin
yikes what would she say if she saw you
say that
probably be very embarrassed would you
say no you came unto me potentially
probably not
just making sure oh that's when you know
you [ __ ] up
oh yeah i did that yeah very awkward
very how old were you guys i mean we
were younger we were like
11 and 13 she was 13.
that's what do we think i
didn't realize we were doing trauma
hours yeah therapy white person therapy
this is white trauma this is a real
white drama this is therapy for me thank
you guys
i was [ __ ] up first you first you
exposed him as being six foot one now
you do this yeah he volunteered that
information a bad week for zach
all right well all right next up um
several of us are going to cross this
one out um you might be white if you
have a podcast you have
a podcast
at one point does that count yeah oh
yeah if you have or have had a party
podcast
experience yeah any podcasting
experience you all hit the board on that
one yeah there you go
right here
hell yeah
all right uh do you love
pumpkin spice lattes are you into
pumpkin spice um what if i like pumpkin
spice but not lattes i think take that
take it i think pumpkin spice generally
smoothies are good yeah pumpkin take it
now i can't say that i'm a huge fan of
the pumpkin spice
i mean i don't hate it
but i don't necessarily
get hyped for it
so i'm going to say no and then i don't
know
i don't it's not on my card and i don't
like pumpkin spice lattes
oof double well you it your your white
passingness is showing i know it's
[ __ ] up maybe twitch was right maybe
i'm not um i don't have the c pass no no
all right uh here here's one that we
just talked about um have you ever
talked about uh quote you are x
percentage native american on a daily
test yeah yeah is that on your card no
oh
mine but i've never done it okay
unfortunately i am 0 native american
unfortunate i that's so funny i didn't
know that was a white person oh yeah oh
yeah but she's always definitely a white
person elizabeth warren did that yeah
white people love uh like being as white
as possible
and then acting like they got some spice
in them you know what i mean like oh
yeah i'm i'm one-eighth
cherokee oh well under attack right now
no i think it's accurate
[Laughter]
um do you put mayonnaise on your
sandwich ew
i have been traumatized by all kinds of
white substances with my career that i
don't want to eat any of them on my food
oh i wish i could tell you on youtube
that's for after the podcast maybe wait
hold up you don't like mayo no
it's disgusting i'm taking your i'm
taking your wordpass yeah you're not
white
actually like i don't really understand
where that comes from i feel like i mean
i know a lot of black people that love
mayo like i don't know i like white
people
i love mayo i feel like that was an
undercover brother joke that like turned
into reality kind of you know what i
mean
because like who doesn't like mayo
sure
me by the way i'm not a huge fan either
what do you put on your sandwich if not
mayonnaise like i don't i have i just
let you hit it raw yeah i let the tomato
juice soak the bread i just eat it wrong
that's some [ __ ] the chicken is
juicy yeah that's madden and not even
like aioli which is the faintest word
for mayo no
it's just male 1 they also didn't fool
anyone with that yeah no they they
really didn't i love aioli but that's
just mayonnaise if your meat isn't dry
and your veggies aren't dry you don't
need sauce that is crazy why make a
sandwich
the sandwich is a vehicle to mix the
sauces with the flavor of the
ingredients if you are gonna put that
beautiful succulent chicken and tomato
in between two slices of bread without
mayonnaise then i don't even know what
the [ __ ] white means
it's easier to pick up as a sandwich
here let me put let me you're getting
really into the whole like you're you're
like throwing bubbles on yourself i just
need to sell it you know we put a lot of
effort into this a lot of effort thank
you guys thank you so much
well i'll have you guys know you need to
be scared because i've got three x's in
a row here really already with the free
with the free photo with the free yeah
all right oh yeah you're on the board
there
all right go ahead what's next all right
um have you ever clapped when the plane
landed
no i can't say i've ever done that no
i've never done that okay i've always
found that really embarrassing it's very
embarrassing but it is very white and
it's very common i feel like someone in
this hot tub is lying
statistically one of you is going to
hassan he's clapped you're [ __ ] like
that's why he laughed no i haven't
he's done it okay it's it's it's great
it's the modern marvel we're flying in
space and the and the pilot was able to
land it perfectly okay it's not you
better bike that [ __ ] you white out i
don't have it i don't have it on mine
but i would [ __ ] i would i would mark
it so hard all right at least you
embrace it i'm coming out of this being
like what power
you know what though it's one of those
things where i'm like oh people are
clapping and but it's also like oh i
want to participate in their joy but i'm
just too jaded and cynical so that's
what i i was meaning but like i have
maybe i don't remember but like i hate
it he definitely definitely but i've
definitely done it where it's like ugh
everyone's clapping like here here it is
participate yeah i'm a disgusting
partner
oh yeah
i wonder if maybe we should do a little
uh note on the side
if you don't have it on your card just
to see who has the most points at the
end
in case no one gets it oh it's too late
i've already yeah i had a couple of
those
i'll say native american yeah that's the
big one for you
and the sunscreen
and sunscreen right yeah
i guess i'll add one for
sunscreen i can't write all this though
come on you just do a tally yeah dude
i don't know what the other ones were
but there was a couple that i didn't
have but i definitely
it definitely featured uh used words
like buddy pal uh had a bowl of marbles
use high spf sunscreen been hit on by a
cousin have a podcast
uh
pump liking pumpkin spice oh never mind
uh
mayo on sandwich that's pretty much it
yeah yeah mayon sandwich we'll take that
one
all right go ahead what's next all right
next is uh
you are uh you are pretty white if you
are a hot yoga enthusiast if you've been
or just ever done hot dogs all right i
have a question for this
so yeah i think so i've never done hot
yoga but i'm enthusiastic about it
so where does that put me like i feel
like i'm always saying to my friends
like we should go to this hot yoga
studio i hear there's a lot of cute
girls that work out there
um
you know
does that put me in the enthusiasm
you've never done it the question is hot
or the category rather is hot yoga
enthusiast you're calling yourself honey
yoga to pick up chicks is not that's not
like
i don't know that i can give him that
point i am a yo i've done yoga she's
done yoga yeah and i live in texas and
it's hot all the time that's that's that
counts okay i've done hot yoga then too
because i've done yoga that's not what
she means you've done hot yoga classes
yeah one time one time one's half one
time i was so sticky it was gross oh
wait you hated it yeah because they
wouldn't let me be naked i don't know if
that's just an enthusiastic how much
they posted they wouldn't let me be
naked so i decided what do you mean
everything she's saying is only you
wanted to move my enthusiasm yeah it was
too hot it was too sticky sure yeah and
i am so it doesn't make sense that you
yeah i guess that's double white people
[ __ ] you wanna
take your clothes off during hot yoga i
don't know
um
i'm not interested in yoga what is hot
yoga they just turn the temperature up i
mean what the [ __ ] yeah like really hot
though yeah because it's like a sauna
yeah really hot your your muscles are
are way more stretchy so you can like
hit certain positions that you normally
wouldn't be able to
so when i'm trying to suck my dick later
oh for sure if you're if you have like i
mean rogan's a big enthusiast no you
probably have a sauna or two in your
house i don't you don't have it in there
i mean i could set up a i could just do
a steamy shower yeah my sucky
yeah there you go you could you could do
that most likely i believe that's called
auto fellatio for those that uh that's
the term but didn't know how to name it
yes actually has the name auto fellatio
so there you have that
wow thank you
um here's one that
uh i've seen evidence of all three of
you um plain salted crackers as a snack
oh it definitely means i mean you're all
hitting the ritz right now the truth is
if i was at home by myself i wouldn't be
hitting the roots no in the pool with
the ritz i'm hitting the ritz okay i'm
100 my plane salted cracker enthusiast
straight up
saltine rich yes any of those for sure
you got it i don't have it but i'm
putting a point down like some of those
are terrible though like wheat thins
like i hate that [ __ ] oh you're [ __ ]
up oh i would eat wheat then straight i
would eat wheat than straight or like a
triscuit
so wait i didn't know those counted
those aren't plain white crackers
my mom didn't know how to cook so i
would often eat plain white crackers as
a snack
oh wow that's pretty desperate
everything is turning in the trauma
right now is that real
like that was a meal just salty and
crackers sometimes cross out your free
space wow because it's a free space what
are you talking about is that how you
play bingo i don't know yeah you get the
free space you get the free space for
free
damn you're talking you're accusing me
of like capitalism on my bingo card i
don't know i've never played i've
[ __ ] never played this game before
people you're definitely not white then
if you've never played yes exactly
you'll never play bingo i don't know
isn't that like an old folks home thing
yeah and
i feel like you do it in school for like
random reasons yeah mm-hmm
yeah
um all right uh do you let your dog
sleep in the bed with you oh hell yeah
absolutely big yes for me i don't have
it but oh yeah i do have it dude i am
crushing i don't have it but i do
take a point do i have it let me see
yeah my dog's definitely sleeping there
i think it's weird behavior when people
don't let their dog sleep in the bed
like are they not part of your family
like dude come on i let the small dog
sleep in my bed but the 200 pound dog i
don't let sleep in my bed because i can
just envision it jumping on the bed and
killing me at night yeah wait what
that's fair it's a health it's a health
condition yeah it's dangerous only cats
do things like that don't worry dogs are
incapable of doing that
that's not true that's not true yeah i'm
a dog supremacist sorry i just i'm a dog
supremacist as well well like my parents
have like a 25 pound uh [ __ ]
it's he's small but he's like a tank and
sometimes he jumps on me and it like
knocks the air out of me now imagine a
200 pound bear with razor sharp claws
you're really 200 pounds yeah holy [ __ ]
the only problem with like a big dog in
the bed is that like i don't know about
you guys but
my dog that uh passed away fish he was
he was a very big boy
he would just like shove his entire body
into me in bed
like he would literally like
you know he would have to like sleep
right on top of me or right next to me
so it got really hot after a while
annoying that's the only annoying thing
like the heat i'm just like oh come on
get off well shredder does that to me
but he weighs seven pounds so
yeah just a cute little heating pad
big like let dogs sleep in bed with you
person though
yeah for sure huge
not on my card though
all right uh
hunting you're gone hunting
never gone hunting no never gone hunting
see that's why we're white passing his
son
because the true whitey
we going hunting now boy that's right
let's get our shots as we going out duck
hunting
i would
okay let me ask sam
have you ever been hunting because
you're from real white [ __ ]
i've never been
she said she's never been
has anybody hunted anybody oh okay so
amber aaron's people
all right they're from texas so yeah
yeah
come on now
wait you been hunting
me no i haven't i haven't my assistants
have apparently one of them
mm-hmm you got a real whitey over here
that's right
all right
uh
getting the bill at a restaurant and
doing the thing where you're like whoa
like you're actually shocked at the
price of the bill yeah i've done that
i've definitely done that
just as a goof you know it's like
my dad does that in my restaurant every
single meal my entire life my dad does
this every time and i guess i just hear
him he picks up and goes like that no
matter what it says yep yeah
i think i've ever done that and i don't
have it you guys have never seen that
happen like
oh my god
no
no
and you guys are missing out real quick
a real turkish thing is like fighting
everyone at the table to pay for the
meal yeah that's like a middle eastern
thing yeah like i gotta pay like you
know
and like or secretly trying to like
oh i gotta go to the bathroom and then
like intercept the bill yep that's
that's they do like 5d chests to play
the yeah there
yeah exactly and then when my dad went
there i guess they expect him to
participate in the same level my dad's
like y'all can pay the [ __ ] bill i
don't give a [ __ ] oh interesting so my
dad has done that to every meal my whole
life the the scaring thing you're saying
your dad did too somebody in the chat is
saying that's a jewish thing
uh so maybe i misunderstood i think it's
it's it's a lot of different cultures i
think asians do that also they fight
over the bill oh i'm sorry i'm talking
about the goo the goof
yeah but you know anybody's has anybody
ever seen a person do the the bill zach
you're jewish does your dad do it yeah
oh no no it's just we've identified a
jewish thing but is it a jew or is it a
cheap thing
okay okay okay sam sam and olivia both
say uh their families do it and they're
not jewish so in all my life i've never
seen anyone do that it's funny you
acknowledge that it's funny yeah yeah
okay thank you oh no absolutely
i've never seen it
yet
like
well it's not on my card so uh [ __ ] and
knock it down
all right next up um are you a fan of
any of the following jack johnson john
mayer dave matthews or jimmy buffett
who come on
jack johnson
john mayer dave matthews or jimmy
buffett i only recognize john mayer john
mayer i love yeah
i think he's like a chill dude all right
you're white
but i i have no i don't like any of
those people
i'm here
i'm happy to say that my jewish side it
wins out this day i i mean but like i
don't listen to his music you know what
i mean you said john mayer is chill that
i got [ __ ] white [ __ ] okay
no i only know that he is an artist okay
you don't think he's chill i have no
idea you're good but i've met him i'm
saying like i've i've hung out with him
i've not like you've met john mayer yeah
you're guilty
is that white behavior yeah even me if
he didn't come in presence with john
mayer's white behavior okay cool then
yeah you're safe well he was like best
yeah yeah you don't want to be white i
mean call lee there's nothing worse than
that oh my god
what could be worse than that don't get
cancelled you gotta chill okay i'm gonna
say john mayer
that's a huge [ __ ]
strike against the he's he's like a
chill dude
i agree with hassan i agree with this
one okay well yeah you're white as [ __ ]
too olivia
olivia's out here being like are people
in the chat mad he's never he's never
been i'm not i don't know anything about
maybe maybe because like they got they
got swifties in the chats with these are
on yours i'm seeing a lot of [ __ ] john
mayer and i'm a swifty yeah i also i
think i'm [ __ ] john mayer
why
because just because that's what the
audio is that's what the audience is
saying probably
[Laughter]
don't speak on this subject i'm not
going to say anything
we have do you mean taylor swift yeah
are you swifty sure yeah whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa
yes just say it trust me don't listen to
ethan
what did i do i'm a slippery i said i'm
a swift dude okay good wait
we're safe i'm so sorry
i think the new stuff let me tell you
something oh no no no no no no
listen thank you listen let me just say
something i already got cancelled by the
swifties because of the cracker stuff
okay
i'm not trying to get like
you know i'm not trying to receive a
mail i just don't like the love the ones
that are like you know the love story
vibe as much because i just feel like
you know romeo and juliet was not a
happy ending that's my only qualm
i feel like i wouldn't want to be like
that story you know you think romeo and
juliet ruins all love songs or i'm not
no no no no i'm i'm saying that doesn't
really fit as a love song because that
was actually a tragedy did she have one
about romeo and juliet yeah i do what
this is that's my only qualm
suicide come on this this i disavow what
that person is saying i'm a swifty
please do not send a mail bomb to my
house it's a catchy song
it's a catchy song for sure are you i
just feel like as a little inaccurate
are you a swifty or a barbie i'm [ __ ]
terrified of the swifties like the barbs
are like whatever you know what i mean
i've already duked it out with them
the swifties i'm worried about because
like you know there's some straight
she's got some great hits she's got bob
she's got bangers no no no the swifties
are tremendous people i take back what i
said about john mayer he [ __ ] that guy
okay all right what's that
thing to do to say [ __ ] john there's
beef between yeah just like everyone
that she's written a song about you have
to hate
[ __ ] john man because they hurt her
feelings [ __ ] that guy 12 years ago
that's not why he did you ever wonder if
they like plan out like like hey i'm
gonna date you that way i can write a
song about you and it'll be published
i'm disavowing doubly what
i'm just wondering if that's ever been
like an application oh my god no that
[ __ ] is real emotion it's real emotion
genuine okay okay swifty for life okay
bts stan as well oh bts we love bts
please please i love you guys
i'm holding a a a sharpie but yes
absolutely do it put the sharpie down
and do it before they box on three yeah
hurry they're watching put the sharpie
down
they'd be like amrap didn't put the
sharpie down to do the heart
yeah i love it no i'm only kidding we
love we stand bts
[ __ ] uh did you see them when they
were here
i tried but the tickets were sold i
couldn't get any tickets damn all my
homies like all the offline tv people
like they all went like vip watched it
see i don't have that cloud i didn't
have that cloud either i didn't get it
like i didn't i would have [ __ ]
wanted to see the phenomenon though oh
my god they're like better than the
beatles
yeah
stand your mind
yeah i stand uh stand you in twice for
good skin
love them both they all have good skin
all right what's next stan let's get off
the stuff uh are you excited do you
do you get excited about uh playing
cornhole
wait wait hold on what is cornhole
because i'm i'm pretty sure i've done
something with corn and holes before but
not yeah not a party game no not that
game
it's the board that's kind of slanted
and it's got some holes in it and then
you take it like a bean bag and you you
toss it there's a video of me on my
instagram absolutely demolishing
cornhole at coachella like i did like a
trick shot like i am i'm oh yes to that
i've never cornholed i have no plans i
think i have a cornhole at an arcade
does that count though it was like an
arcade game no are you thinking about
ski ball
because it's similar but but i don't
think that quite qualifies i physically
get excited when there's corn hole about
so like you know you're day drinking and
then all of a sudden there's like a
little opportunity to play a little corn
hole oh [ __ ] yeah dude i've never look
at that look at that beaut
oh bean bags i think yeah i thought we
were throwing corn in there from texas
right now i remember this game yes
yeah we called that bean toss when i was
a kid come on down to the bean toss now
yeah i love that there's a rogue fitness
one like
you want to play pornhole but you're not
a [ __ ] get through
we call that we call that beanbag toss
now yeah there's an american flag on it
too so you know
you don't come across feminine or
something throwing a bag of corn around
it's a bag of beans monochrome space for
it played it once or what
you have the be you have the corn hole
no i don't have it
for the point when you get that yeah
yeah if you're enthusiastic i want to
get the rogue fitness cornhole with the
punisher decal on it like you know blue
lives matter blue lives matter carnival
we totally do a coho product for the
police now yeah i'm throwing this bean
bag for all the police that this one's
from all the fallen soldiers yeah that's
right brother i've never i'll tell you
how i've never even been in the vicinity
of a
corn holing situation are you saying no
way i don't know where it is so much
less white
i don't even [ __ ] in the same
uh at i'm not even in the same
gravitational field as a cornhole set
you went to college in santa cruz nobody
corn holes in santa cruz what you got i
doubt that there's definitely what the
[ __ ] you talking about there's
definitely cornholes there is no
cornholing in santa cruz i feel like
period yeah you never had an elementary
not that i remember
i just i i categorized those frisbee and
[ __ ] people are not cornholing
that's not a cornhole city i've just
definitely all all cities that are part
of the uc is cornhole city cornhole
central i'm gonna give you a corn hole
okay
i'll bend you over this is are you
trying to get demonetized or like oh i'm
pretty good with the boundaries i'm good
with what i should say
something yeah it's not that bad i've
said much worse
uh
official uh banana slug
uh you see someone who's cornhole uh
[ __ ]
what call it student what what is this
website victory tailgate
yeah this is like the frat boys get
together they're like yo dude no college
kid is spending 180 bucks first of all
yes i'll tell you how i know this is
[ __ ] there's these the whole oh my
god
okay i'm sorry i have to back down
my one of my best friends just text me i
guess he's watching he went to uc santa
cruz he said no one cornhole's insanity
[ __ ] thank you i wish people would
just listen to me
[ __ ] but there's usually at usc doesn't
have a sports team their best their most
prolific sports team is ultimate frisbee
[ __ ] aren't buying brands yeah
usc they're you're right
machines i feel like this is real fratty
[ __ ] like if they're are there
fraternities no there's nothing bro
there's no opportunities in santa cruz
if there are fraternities in santa cruz
there's cornhole i promise you people
just smoke weed there bro it's not like
that
it's not like that
that's a different vibe there
all right next up uh
are you obsessed with the true crime
podcast
yes yes
no
uh i think i've seen one episode of true
crime
you don't [ __ ] with true crime you don't
get that point that's crazy i am big
true crime boy right here shouts out the
jcs new video that came out i can't wait
to watch it on stream
one day
or 2020 or any of that [ __ ] no i i'm
like
i i i support the youtube content
creators that make uh you know these
true crime uh [ __ ] like interrogation
videos
have you ever seen the jcs stuff i don't
know who that is uh it's like it's like
a channel that like literally just rips
straight footage
of of interrogations of like prolific
murderers things like that and then
they'll add like you know
pseudo-scientific nonsense on top of it
like
he crossed his legs that means he likes
to [ __ ] a man's open skull yeah that's
like that's that sounds scientific to me
that's very accurate yeah no that's
that's uh straight my [ __ ] you know well
i'll tell you i love
i know people are gonna call me boomer
or something but 2020 dateline are the
greatest [ __ ] truth those
[ __ ] they have the con they
have the interviews the confessions they
do the whole damn thing hi shredder can
i help you
maybe shredder you want to come out of
the cracker pit
you want to lay on me
[Music]
yeah sorry shreddy let's let's get you
out of here what is this music what's
going on that's the shrimp that's the
shredder the music the shredder's
cuteness thing oh yeah shredder i don't
want you all covered in cracker grease
and should i just paint you
i just bathed myself before i came on a
big mistake
all right um
moving on uh
you love brunch
i love love
we love friends oh my god you too i [ __ ]
with brunch but wait is that really a
white people thing brunch oh yeah oh
yeah i mean not exclusive none of these
are exclusively white obviously but it's
definitely yeah it's definitely up there
yeah dude these are so good black people
don't [ __ ] with brunch
well of course they do but it's just i
mean when you go get mimosas
in the early morn or the last is a white
person yeah he's right i mean like that
i love mimosas accurate yeah shrek oh
shredder's back in the cracker oh he
said i wanna shutters drowning and
come here crackers baby what's up come
here cracker boy what's up all right you
want to be in the cracker pit you can be
in the cracker pit
hello
you're so beautiful shredder no
cute
stinky breath king yeah he does have
stinky breath your stinky breath all
right what are we doing next all right
uh do you put an h before w
uh in any words that you say for example
kuh whip
i mean just i mean as a joke yeah i've
only done it as a joke is if it's just a
stupid like joke does that count when i
want to make something more appear more
white i do it
right
hmm
yeah i don't know i mean if you do it a
lot even if it's ironic i feel like i
don't do it still kind of i can't take
the cool crib
no
uh how about the next one uh
wearing shoes in the house
oh big pet peeve of mine that is
disgusting white people behavior yeah i
don't do that i hear it my parents never
said take your shoes off so that's what
we did the whole thing i don't do that
[ __ ] you know you know i don't do that i
come from a shoe in the house family
amaranth was at my house like two days
ago when we did the thing and i was like
immediately what was the first thing i
said i was like everybody take your
shoes off i mean i took my shoes because
yeah you dare shredder
you gotta give me a break here i can't
do the show like this
all right
we gotta do some shredder come on dude
you give me a break
there you go
uh yeah so i come from a house of shoe
wears inside which is weird because my
mom is such a clean freak
and uh that's crazy now we have a no
shoe policy but i find shoe in the house
it's disgusting repulsive i agree
well
it's just especially because i go to the
barn i'd be stepping in actual [ __ ]
if you put it if you put it on
especially if you like sit on a couch
with your shoes on it's like not jail
straight up
shoes yeah yeah what are you doing dude
like you're gonna put that [ __ ] on my
couch or bed immediately oh god
execution
yeah unfortunately i had to mark that
one off i haven't i can't have shoes i
need a man
so you would you also come from a shoe i
do
it's like humiliated using it that's
gross that's part of our white uh
heritage that we try to ignore yeah
that's not the good part no is there a
good part
um
oh yeah come on come on come on you're
on the clock barbecue
explain so that's the funniest part
that's a white person thing yeah it's
not i think the i think the blacks the
black americans get that one that was i
just remember having fun like yeah that
was the white house gatherings and the
black americans so
so that's like that's the other part of
that this is like how do you declare
your allegiance to the white folk like
you know what i mean because people are
like you're anti-white racist i'm like
no i love white people and it's like
someone's like prove it i'm like
i don't know like what am i supposed to
say i think that's the only time my
family ever did something with other
humans was during a barbecue and that's
like when i got to see friends that's
fun or pretend are you from texas yeah
so that that could be the barbecue thing
yeah maybe what do white people do good
um let's see
hmm hamburger
can we do the hamburger is that a white
person thing i don't even know isn't
that german i think that's that's as
real white okay
hamburgers
love that pizza
again we're i like pizza i mean i'm i'm
half italian you know fantastic i like
pizza and i like people
and i like hey come on forget about it
papa john's huh all right move it on all
right uh have you ever seen is not a
pizza is not white people food it's
italian
right we're making a joke or something
you don't have to i get it a lot of
people aren't all the same here eat some
what defines white versus italian what
does that mean is there poc
okay that's the angle you're going
italians are people of color oh they're
marginalized there's a lot of italian
phobia in today's society absolutely
why you may feel that as a half italian
yourself you don't i feel like people
are just scared of me as a person not
because i'm italian no it's because
you're italian they know i felt your
presence immediately
[Laughter]
it's powerful all right all right
uh have you ever said oh no here comes
trouble
what who says that what no
oh my god that's awesome maybe when
shredder enters the room as a goof here
comes trouble there you go here comes
trouble i said it might be about
theodore you've said that that's white
as [ __ ] yeah okay i'll take it that's
the whitest thing i've heard so far
i say here comes trouble when shredder
oh shucks our theodore here comes some
trouble
yeah i'll take that
all right uh
have you ever worn shorts when uh it was
40 degrees yes oh hell yeah he's
exclusively he literally is currently
doing that right now it's like 40
degrees out exclusively my dude that's
craziness i mean i did it this morning
too so technically yeah not on my list
though but that's the workout though
that's not because like i'm the extra
dud there's not i've only done that to
work out does that count
no
like outdoors stolen valor bro
yeah stolen white valor i'm not taking
that
all right go ahead all right uh do you
um enjoy camping
i've never been camping i think i would
like it though
i hate candy you never even been camping
no my my family never went camping
you can't claim that can she claim that
if she thinks she would enjoy it because
you don't know until you yeah i can't
claim it i have no idea you're not
missing out okay camping is one of the
most overrated activities straight up
sucks i mean people like to glamorize it
but at the end of the day you're leaving
your beautiful warm home thank you to go
live in a goddamn [ __ ] i think
camping like in a cabin would be fun
that's not good that's not camping
glamorous camping is what you'd be into
straight up that is the reason why
that's white people [ __ ] is like oh i
have nothing bad going on in my life let
me [ __ ] it up
i'm going to go rough it up yeah
having heat at my house yeah it's like
liver king here
yeah liver king loves camping
he's probably camping right now liver
king liver king here today he's got a
little bit of a lisp
you know
you are a stand bro uh liver king here
we're going out to do
a successful uh camping trip to uh
simulate a successful hunt why is he
british royal i don't know who liver
king here
i've got so much living here i'm i'm
high on crap royalty yes i'm the little
monarch i'm eating a lot of crackers
i have it on my card but i just cannot
say i enjoy camping yeah it sucks yep
but i can't sorry all right have you
ever said okey dokey
every day
every day of my life yep it's not on my
card though uh it's on my car i think
i've definitely said okey dokey for sure
[Laughter]
okay
is it have i ever said okey dokey or do
you regularly use that i use it every
day but i don't know what the card is i
love the okie dokie yeah
i can't say that i use that word
regularly as much as i would love to
take it because it puts me right in
striking zone okey dokey is just like a
lighter way of saying okay because
sometimes in a text okay can look too
serious people okie dokie sometimes yeah
oh [ __ ] that's pretty bad that's white
that's why that's pretty bad because i
feel like okay
it's weird
but like okay okay it comes up a little
cold yeah exactly so you say okay
i can't tell if it's words that i've
said okey dokey i've never texted that i
would never text okie dokie you think
it's worse to say it out loud or text it
they're both pretty bad okay well i mean
i've said it
so
ah it sucks because i'm like myself it
seems like i'm allowed to say cracker
yeah definitely like for
sure matters context is definitely
important
yeah like i'm saying like i should be
able to as a cracker call another white
person a cracker
yeah it's our word that's what i'm
saying if italians aren't white i don't
think you can claim it either that's the
issue double oppressed that's what i'm
talking about
they're doubly oppressed
because they can't say cracker dude it's
our word to say now we were saying if
you were to use the word cracker would
you hit it with a hard er or soft a at
the end uh i don't think i would do
either you wouldn't i just wouldn't hit
you you're so worried about hitting it
with the lid
would you hit that e
yeah or would you crack a
i think both sounds questionable
all right we were saying yesterday
krakow sounds almost more racist it's
worse yeah yeah yeah definitely that's
interesting it's like this is doing like
aave almost like you're doing
african-american vernacular isn't that
not called ebonics or did they change
yeah they changed it oh so what's it
called now aave
tr here let's get alfredo a pillow
what's up all freaking a little cracker
oasis
come here alfredo let's get you a
cracker oasis
is that big enough for you
no i think like
maybe building a
hot tub
full of crackers and having your dogs
hang out on pillows on it is definitely
caucasian behavior well you know what i
don't deny that let me tell you the next
question is do you let your
pet kiss you on the lips straight up
straight up
not even a question i will kiss other
people's dogs too on the lips no dog
lips are safe around me brother
okay
it's not on my [ __ ] dogs
don't say that
you're gonna cancel don't say that
oh no here comes rebels
oh oh yeah here comes trouble that's why
i say here comes trouble i say damn
that's a good looking
whoa whoa whoa here comes some trouble
right here
he's just trying to he's just trying to
hit those cheese
alfred are you coming here for the damn
cheese oh yeah you're in a pool of
crackers and he just wants cheese
so um obviously as people know in the
show i let my dogs lick me in on the
face and um
you guys are causing so much trouble
right now um let's just get him out of
here
maybe go give him the eel or something
sorry guys this cracker situation is
is causing a lot of complications for us
sorry all right while he's grabbing the
dogs uh have you ever unironically said
jeez louise oh yes definitely absolutely
brother that one i i yeah like this geez
i've said i say it like once a stream
that one's a good thing we can all cross
that one out yeah i don't have it on my
own
oh my god oh my god you know what you
know what's stopping me okay i need to
say something here
no we need we need to go back to hot
yoga no bro i said i didn't take the
okie dokie okay but i'm i'm enthusiastic
about hot yoga you never been to hot
yoga don't do white people stolen valor
sorry
i'm never gonna win this i'm looking at
the board and it's like there's nothing
on the
[ __ ]
well you are we've got quite a few more
from stuff too we got a few more go
ahead dan keep going um
do you know the words to drops of
jupiter by train
no i have no i don't even know what that
is nope and if i had that that would be
a bingo for me too we can't play a lot
of it because it's a copyright song but
we'll play like two seconds of it and
you'll immediately know this if you
start singing along your way right
exactly okay
so stand by
setting it up
i want to know
[Music]
yesterday bro i have no [ __ ] clue
what you definitely know that song play
more play more please i've literally
never just
i've never heard this you guys are full
of it keep playing play more we're going
to get clean tell me
where'd you wait
that's the song yeah yeah
see i don't even know the lyrics
play the chords go to the part i've
before but i don't know the lyrics yeah
right you listen that [ __ ] every night
no
no no no no no
the drop the drop you're trying to get
me glenn just go to the club i'm trying
to find it i do i don't drop a
[Music]
drop some revenue in the jupiter's
pocket at this rate here it is
[Music]
okay stop it
okay yeah i know but i don't know the
lyrics i feel like i've probably heard
it before but like i don't know the
lyrics
like i know the i can hum along to it
yeah it's not a i think we both it's
never something i've like sought out i'm
like man i've really got to listen to
the drops of jupiter yeah i think we can
all
skip the drops of jupiter
i don't know ethan you've seen it i only
knew it because you played it for me
yeah you know the first chord of that
name
okay i'll take the point i don't know
that song i'm literally saying word for
word
okay here
truman
that's all i know
don't act like you don't know now not
even fall down
in her ear
okay whatever i'll take the dubs
what are the drops of jupiter in here
you're supposed to it's so dumb
hair in her hair and her hair don't know
what it means it's it's word salad
definitely is his name jupiter and he's
like i'm dropping
in her hair she's juicing in her hair
yeah yeah
maybe i've never done that do we have
any intel on if he's [ __ ] in her hair
lyric genius
nice final fantasy it's that she's
traveled so much and experienced so much
that she's gone all the way to jupiter
and back oh okay av that sounds like an
acid trip av do you have did you do soft
report
i don't know i jim i jam out today song
hell yeah oh
[Music]
wait what's your what's your ethnicity
baby
my father is lebanese and my mom is
german irish i [ __ ] knew it dude
that's right there you go first of all
too handsome
that's what it is these people are very
lebanese people are you know the whitest
people in the middle east mena region
what did you mean too handsome that's
why lebanese people are very handsome oh
he's saying he's beautiful he's got that
lebanese yeah okay [ __ ] thank you
thought he about to get canceled would
you would you would your dad say he's uh
[ __ ] this is the intricacies of lebanese
politics i don't know if we should get
into it would he say he's arab or does
he hate when people say you're arab no
he'll say he's arab oh okay well muslim
then
yeah he'll say he's muslim yeah okay
never mind
he's a civil rights attorney that's why
bro
yeah no no because uh christian there's
like christian lebanese people that now
they say they're phoenician their mother
and hate being called arrows right like
my my main man naseem talib
anyway let's keep going okay awesome
this is not on the white person card
yeah you lost it yeah yeah i've already
i'm sorry just by knowing any of that
you lost several points okay okay
the intricacies of lebanese politics
this is too far beyond the pale for
white folk
yeah are you [ __ ] joking yeah what
are you talking about you're speaking at
least american yeah that's more american
uh okay uh draws to jupiter where uh i
lost my place oh um do you like wes
anderson movies
who's that i love wes anderson there you
go uh what santa said he made royal
tannenbaum
movies where he made it
the fantastic fox he made the island the
dogs he made uh steve's i haven't seen
any of these movies like aquatic
bottle rockets rushmore i haven't seen
any of these you've never seen any of
those no single west anderson movie
they're all so good you love it wait
what do you do
i i stream and i throw ass and make
money bro you are literally sitting in
between two of the most like non-stop
streaming
andy's on twitch like yeah but you've
seen that [ __ ]
well at least you have time to play
cornhole yeah when i was growing up not
anymore well now it's a different kind
of cornhole it's
darching and lum unlimited
what's the hotel one he made recently
too
uh hotel budapest hotel budapest
okay the framing is like is it actually
colors are great it's like a claymation
movie about dogs yeah cool it's really
good
it's really good definitely recommend it
um
getting pretty gross these crackers eh
getting kind of greasy and [ __ ] you're
smart you're on a pillow i'm in the oh
yeah i'm in there
and you got
into the thick of it yeah
into the thick of it i don't know what
that is but i feel like knowing that is
extremely caucasian behavior too oh what
is this i think it's a tick-tock thing i
don't think backyardigans is white he
doesn't take tacos oh i don't know i
don't know what it is sorry i didn't
grow up here [ __ ] i shouldn't have said
that i grew up here in america
why shouldn't you say you didn't grow up
because i feel like this is not white no
it's not yeah literally not what i mean
i know why i'm lying i'm a liar all
right what's next
um
you don't have lips
what the [ __ ] does that mean people have
no upper lips
nothing i think we're all go i think we
all got limbs big ass lips i don't know
everybody everybody always makes fun of
me whenever i shave they say like oh you
have no upper lip they say that sounds
like then i think you take that one yeah
you might have that one and so
i mean i don't have it on my thing so it
doesn't even matter okay
well you mark it down because you're
white as [ __ ]
you're a white dude
all the italian side of my family has
nice lips
big italian juicy lips huh
i i think you've got an upper lip but
you know you ain't no italian you ain't
got that juicy look mustache makes it
hard to tell
yeah i think you have a lip i mean i
don't know what about now
beautiful i see a lip i that's right i
don't know what to say
i got an upper lip whatever that's right
shut up everybody
uh have you ever uh
i'm not sure i quite understand this one
ian maybe you can clarify dressed up a
pet in matching outfits like i've done
that between the two not understand that
well like are you matching your pet or
you have two pets that are both you
matter
okay well i've done that okay well there
you go i've done that i will go to the
fabric store and i will cut squares to
turn into bandanas that match my active
outfits and go on a walk with my dog
all right so i've never done that but
i've never gonna i've definitely dressed
up my pets in like various different
like i've i've dressed up my pets in
like themes you know what i'm saying
like like costumes like a hot dog or
something yeah but you don't match it
but i don't match it no see i dressed my
uh dog up as max from the grinch the
grinch's dog oh yeah yeah and then i
cosplayed one of santa's hoes so we were
santa's hose and the grinch's dog yeah
the iconic duo i think you definitely
qualify you retconned that a little bit
i feel like or were there santa's hoes i
don't know he has three of them
santa has hoes
three of them
like mrs claus i mean she's one of them
but there's two more that they don't
talk about they're just because santa's
got side girls like yeah
why do you think he says ho ho yeah
exactly i can't tell if you guys are
[ __ ] with me or not i i really don't
know that intricacies
oh hello i thought it was just something
he said i didn't realize calling his
girls he said get the [ __ ]
misogynistic i'm gonna haram bro stop
that we're gonna say santa work santa
works hard during christmas you gotta
get his nut
he gotta get his stack he's gotta get
that see gotta refill that
before the next beginning
because like that's the whole i saw i
saw
he's coming down the chimney he's got
more than one hoe he's got hoes in
different areas true three in the north
pole and then across the world also yeah
yeah they say fifty percent of the
genealogy extended enough traces back to
santa claus i think you're talking about
genghis khan yeah i was kind of
referring to yeah genghis khan is santa
claus he did not give you gifts or the
gifts that he gave you did not want no
yeah all right what's next all right uh
can you do you know off the top of your
head more than two lacroix flavors
what's the what's that definitely what's
lacroix oh my goodness oh what lacroix
the flavored soda water
it's oh i don't drink it i just
know about is that one of the curse of
writing like that's right
yeah i know see now this is [ __ ] if i
took the okie dokie i would be and okay
well that's the same with me and [ __ ]
but i've had a lot of people in there
same with me in hot yoga
there's been a lot of bingos in the chat
i'm surprised uh yeah well we're just
not white and we're not white enough i
guess well she's cherokee
i'm jewish right you know he's turkish
so i'm also italian i'm double yeah
you're you're basically a minority i
feel like amaranth took what i said
seriously about italians are not white
and now she's going oh she's right
you're right you were right don't you
can't take that [ __ ] back you're right
too late yeah
all right have you ever played ultimate
frisbee yes yes
mark it down do i have it
do i have it
i feel like i have not played ultimate
frisbee
if you would like that guy i've thrown
frisbees around
that's not my life but it's not
ultimately not the same no no in school
i'm pretty sure we played it i played
boneless frisbee not ultimate frisbee
next uh have you ever referred to target
as tarjay yes yes doesn't everyone do
that oh my god dude
all the time down nonstop yes tarjay
obviously all the time
uh this one i know ethan's got uh socks
and sandals
yeah whoa straight up guilty as charged
i don't have it on me but i got
i've done it i don't like to but i've
done it that's it
actually i've never done socks and
sandals i do socks and slides all the
time though but that's not a white
person's [ __ ] socks and slides counts
socks as light is not white people [ __ ]
anyone who's ever went to basketball
camp knows socks and slides is straight
up not that is not like a like a white
exclusive sandals on the other hand
certainly you're talking about like with
the point between the big toes right
yeah
yeah i'm talking i'm talking
like like adidas slippers or whatever
like the slides what are sandals
considered the toe yeah or
the toe because like that's what you
wear like because you know that's pretty
gnarly i've done it too
it's just not good at all it's just it's
just because you're wearing socks inside
your house and then you have to go
outside for like a little bit yeah you
put on the the flippies and you're like
oh bro i'll just be straight up i've
gone to work with socks and [ __ ]
sandals oh god yeah
like today
yeah well i know i have no i'm working
off no i don't do that anymore i wear
slides
but when i used to work in an office
back in israel when i lived there i
would [ __ ] roll up with socks and
sandals like a pure degenerate that's
crazy
all right ella's dad actually almost
disowned me because he told me to stop
wearing sandals and socks to their house
he was a smart man he thought it was
disrespectful
all right have you ever uh
done the hand surfing thing outside the
window of your car
and that's embarrassing but what is the
hand surfing thing so like you put your
hand out the window oh yeah i've done
that yeah
um do i have that i don't think i have
it no
no
oh [ __ ] yeah it really changes when
someone leans forward
all right duh have you
have you ever put your kid on a leash or
were you put on a leash as a kid
no i definitely would put my kid on the
leash but i don't have a kid oh [ __ ]
okay you should claim that first of all
that that's a check i think
to be able to say that out loud i mean i
think that's like the craziest [ __ ]
well as the only person in the tub with
a kid i thought it was the craziest
thing but now i can see i actually see
that it's kind of dope
i wouldn't it's not that i wouldn't
trust my kids i don't want my kid to be
walking next to me and someone to come
grab my kid yeah there's a million
reasons why it's actually amazing yeah
and they could have more freedom to run
around you have to like police them all
the time yeah and control over there i
wouldn't i don't think i would do it
because it's so embarrassing this is the
most i think anything i've ever heard i
think i would only do it in a high
traffic place like where someone could
come up and grab my kids like that's
dangerous exactly being afraid that your
child is going to be victim to
kidnapping is also extremely why people
[ __ ] though well that's also just
influencer [ __ ] yeah oh that's true
that's true that's different yeah you're
right about that i don't know i mean i
don't want to get lost either it's like
if you're at disney it's shoulder to
shoulder you know and they want to
wander around and [ __ ] around and you
don't necessarily want to be like you
have to hold my hand at all times right
then you can put them on a leash and say
run free you know be with that's right
you don't have like one of those
extendable leashes like a dog okay
i think you both are able to
you've convinced me that you're you can
take the point
that's not on my mind you spent yeah
on a child you deserve
i have a kid i have credentials
uh have you ever owned a pickup truck
yes
no not on my list though i'm about to i
think i might get one oh really like
literally today maybe even really you
can take the point then okay look how
fat my thighs look bro yeah you look hot
thick what the [ __ ]
is that like the angle thick why do they
look like that
i also used to own a
tahoe too yo they look like big old
[ __ ] freak
yeah you tree stumps
you got big boy legs what the hell
[ __ ]
i gotta put those things away yeah
you're you're just flexing at this point
all right we're we're
coming down to the wire here there's
about there's not that many left so
hopefully i already i know how i'm going
to win this but it's just not all right
keep them coming down keep them coming
um
after a group photo have you said okay
now let's take a silly one yes yes i
haven't said that actually
i've said that
well aren't you just silly i always also
say say cheese
i say cheese cheese theodore especially
he loves saying cheese
well
all right uh have you ever made a green
bean casserole
no no i've eaten i've eaten one i think
but not made one yeah
yo yours is looking dangerous right now
this is going to come down striking
distance
oh see the other one is super weird
we'll see keep going keep going keep
going i have one that's like is it
that's a lock
oh that's a lock
[Laughter]
go ahead dan keep going uh have you ever
uh held up a fish for a photo
yes yes actually i have i have done that
oh yeah yeah
not on my list not on my [ __ ] card
dude wait would you say fishing is
hunting is the type of hunter no
no not quite no okay okay i don't think
he's different with a gun
hunting is seeking out your prey fishing
is hoping something bites it it's a
little different
also one you should kill things with a
gun yeah or bonus or bow yeah or a spare
or a beer spare hands if you're yeah if
you wrestle it with your liver king you
just kill them with your bare hands
um
do you say oop or no you're fine when
you bump into somebody definitely yeah
yeah it's me yeah it's not online it's
not on my card either you gave us bad
cards you're giving me a [ __ ] card
dude totally random i just hit bingo
oh
read the ones that you got yeah what was
the five kissing pet on the lips saying
oh or no you're fine where you're
bumping into someone then my free space
uh excited about cornhole i love that
[ __ ] and uh saying oh no here comes
trouble wow congratulations congrats
what is this prize
uh we don't really have a price you
could go take one of the crackers from
the weekend
whole set for the for him we do have a
prize for form actually oh you do oh yes
bring it out grab it okay well
congratulations to zach our resident
whitey how do you feel buddy you're the
you're the king's cracker you got the
you have the c card
yeah you can say cracker with a hard er
now you get the pass congratulations
i'm adding uh a camera really quick one
second okay zach do you want us to give
a speech
i'm a white jewish kid that's all i can
say
um
[Laughter]
right i knew i was white but i you
didn't know you were this i didn't know
i was this white very white
this is the worst couple of weeks for
zach i swear to god it came out as white
cousins came out of six foot one
all right what do we got there we got a
plate of food let me see
we made him a special dish uh as a
reward for winning does this look like
my family's dinner oh that's straight up
like what i had growing up really yes
some potatoes some carrots some peas and
some plain non-seasoned chicken broth
you ate that
yep oh that's straight punishment yeah
that's
child abuse that's every day that's my
that's actually more
more stuff on my plate than i had as a
kid do people really not eat or do
people really eat unseasoned chicken
yeah
you have salt and pepper in the middle
the table and you do what you want you
just do a little salt and pepper yeah
how the [ __ ] you gonna cook chicken and
not put some seasoning on it like god
damn that's called uh you know
white 101
didn't know that about white people yep
i really don't think i'm that white guys
i have to say
the sunday boil so am i do you want me
to take a break dig into this yeah so go
ahead zach
doesn't look bad
well you are the winner so i wouldn't be
surprised i would just say it doesn't
surprise me that you would say that it's
like so nasty it's like my mother's just
make sure it's cooked
sam is just cooking
uh
bro i have corduroys on these things
yeah i'm looking at your pants are
totally [ __ ] like i'm gonna sit in the
car and the car is gonna get [ __ ] take
a bite get it all in there
yeah mix it all together mix it up what
is this it was just
way too big
yeah it's a huge bite dude but okay i
love me some chicken all right get in
there now that is the worst
oh
nostalgic taste come on
there it is that's why that's why you
won my dude that's why you won right
really good tastes like colonization
tastes like manifest destiny
that's the craziest thing is like
british people like their og cuisine has
like no [ __ ] spices even though they
literally colonize after right for it
that's interesting it's just so strange
to me like at least they never figured
out how to use the damn spices right
they knew they were valuable but they
didn't know what to do with them
should we rapid fire the last couple
just yeah why don't you just read them
off yeah okay uh
ipa enthusiast
um don't use a washcloth
uh punched a hole in like well
don't wait oh bingo oh there you go guys
what's a don't use a washcloth yeah what
the [ __ ] does that mean it's just using
the soap bearer on your body using the
soap
yeah i do i use a washcloth you want to
take a bite without a loop
uh i prefer the washcloth just because i
feel like i can like use it better for
exfoliation because it's a scary i like
on my face to exfoliate but i use the
bar soap straight up
i hit the saw bra every time i do raw
yeah there you go
yeah all right you guys want to know
what i i got bingo wait what do you do
with the wet washcloth those sounds like
i hang it i like i
i wash it in the shower though don't
even bring it and you reuse it don't do
that to me
sometimes how long before okay i'll try
it i'll try it out yeah oh my god oh god
salmonella use the same washcloth
usually like two bone apple tea boys
that's not bad yeah
oh oh i see what's happening here oh
that looks so good oh this is the
nastiest only only winners get the white
dinner bro are you kidding me this is so
bland oh that looks like home we
colonized the earth for this [ __ ] hassan
it's straight gains bro bro that [ __ ]
literally looks you don't want a bite of
this it looks like a tv dinner but like
so that exactly was why i was never an
overweight child
i had this it's hard yeah yeah od on
this yeah you want to try this no i'm
good nice for whites only yeah right
yeah
it's just a potato bro it's not that you
act like it's so disgusting oh it's so
nasty because it's got like the carrot
the carrots are kind of cold i'll give
you that oh it's got the carrot juices
on it so he's got like a carrot oh i
can't eat that it's so bad it's just
potato and carrot you're being so
dramatic i need like i need some [ __ ]
foot crackers to shove in my mouth
i love potatoes crackers oh yeah
yeah that chicken breast because it's
looking pretty kind of sad but okay take
it away thank you so much
you want to just read off all the
options because we got all these funny
ones uh yeah there's only there's just a
handful left yeah i just finished it uh
uh punched a hole in drywall just said
had a beach themed or rustic themed room
in your house see that would have given
me bingo
uh vampire
vampire weekend fan um
uh a yelled uh play free bird at a
concert
um
i think that's all of them i see you
doing dangerous [ __ ] and called right
yes you're right calling it
doing dangerous [ __ ] and calling it
recreation that's me yeah horse riding
that's some dangerous [ __ ] for fun true
yeah yeah what was that black writing
yeah that's not dangerous i was a
horseback rider it can be yeah people
get really injured doing that i was a
professional
i was a show jumper in turkey what does
that mean
i jumped with my horse over obstacles
yeah that's what i want to do you want
to know how white people should that is
i'm a horse girl
i don't know how white people say that
is you have to wear like those tight
tights on your pants this is [ __ ]
terrible you got to wear chaps
and then up top you have to wear a
button up they're called breeches oh
chaps are different yeah yeah well i
don't know what it's called in english
we used to say cheps uh for the you can
have like short chaps though it doesn't
have to be up to your ass anyway
whatever the distinction is is
you guys just trying to flex on me how
white you are and i'm stuck in the
middle i would wear button up sharp
that awful [ __ ] tie that was like
frizzly it's like a white tie with like
weird texture on it
and then a blazer a navy or a red blazer
on the helmet
yeah that's like the show jumping outfit
no isn't he the worst jockey though like
guys that's not a jockey that's not a
jockey jockey ladies and gentlemen
jumping in not racing yeah jockeys are
first so you can be a big guy if you're
a jumper yeah that's fine
i mean i think i'm too big now back then
i wasn't that was you yeah
i won that the 80 you took the dub on
that yeah no way
i competed at is your family rick the
below entry they used to be when i was
growing up what happened
my dad lost
all of the money how did that happen
i think like futures trading or
something oh [ __ ] he lost no trading
what is that why you stopped doing
horses or like why no i hated it when i
was growing up you didn't like riding
horses no because like it's such a
solitary uh like it's such a solitary
sport
all my friends play basketball and i
want to play basketball and they were
like no you're gonna horseback ride i
didn't have any friends and i wanted to
do horse riding would have been perfect
for it i wanted to i wanted to [ __ ]
play basketball with my friends and they
were like no you have to do horseback
wait how much money did your dad lose on
the doing like
future trading like millions
i don't know probably
i don't know but he was we were
definitely um was he like a gambling
addict or something
or just bad investor he's a bad investor
i mean that is gambling though future
trading is literally gambling so
technically yeah yeah i mean wow shout
outs to the dads i guess yeah
no more horses in your [ __ ] life yeah
but no the the horseback riding arm i
stopped after uh my horse passed away
oh
that's sad but it was it was sad but it
was also a little liberating at the same
time because like i didn't want to do it
um what how did your horse die
i think it was like kidney failure
that's yeah there's a lot of things that
can go wrong horses are pretty fragile
yeah really because they're so big and
muscular and they seem so like they're
also like dogs like their personality i
think closely resembles like big dogs
but it's true really yeah a lot smarter
how long do horses usually live they can
live to like to 30 yeah good average for
horses if they're healthy yeah yeah it's
a long time
wow there requires a lot of maintenance
though like a lot of maintenance oh yeah
they're expensive
dude i wish my dogs would live to 30 and
that would be like heaven
i would love that so much i wish they'd
one day maybe they'll get that figured
out we need stem cell research on dogs
[ __ ] humans that is so fun that's why
people [ __ ] i mean i agree with you yes
but also
i don't care what's going on in the
third world i just want my dogs to live
longer it's
great true
accurate statement yeah
all right i got to get out of this
[ __ ] pool i i agree you guys want to
wrap it up it's horrible well we have
more games right we do have other games
but we are kind of quick
quick quick let's do them let's do them
okay we're only going to be in this pool
once yeah i mean someone else gets
banned for it let's just try to move
through okay so you guys want to do yeah
if the sun gets banned again we can come
back with more with more so we have two
that are basically they're visual save
these they're visual games that you you
need to compare things uh one is called
mayo in the mirror where we have to
decide if white people are the same
person mayo and the mirror or we have uh
uncooked chicken or shirtless white man
let's do that one first okay what is
that game well i'll show you
oh my
uh one second is it gonna be like a
white man's titty and you to decide if
it's his breast or the chicken breast um
because that would be
peak content kind of like that
pretty similar
to what you just described can you tell
me if these are
fresh sir
[Music]
let's just
way
say
blurred oh it's a blurry that's the game
that's a chicken no no that's a white
man that's a white shirt he gets a white
man i'll tell you what i see i see a
white man who's like jumping in a pool
yeah that's a white man
jones i think it's a white man i think
you're right that's not alex jones
it could be a chicken breast though i
think he's a young alex jones he has
like a pool noodle or something he's
carrying maybe i don't know something
like he's falling his hands around oh it
could be his arms you're right it could
be his arms he's like catching something
maybe or falling go ahead final answer
what are we saying white man white man
white man
you got it yeah
what the [ __ ] like a marble yeah what
the [ __ ]
it was too easy so we've we've put a lot
of them into environments that will make
it more ambiguous what you're seeing
very tricky yeah very tricky
all right so next
um can you hear me okay
yeah
oh i see what you're doing yes we can
hear you
that's chicken breast next
yeah chicken breast
that's literally chicken breast on a
beef i agree
same
that is a chicken breast on the beach
love that
uh next up
oh really this one's tough yeah
oh i see the chat is saying ritz tits
yup exactly
that could be a chicken breast
on a horse i'm not sure
uh i think it's chicken i think it's a
man i think it's chicken because you're
trying to trick us
i think it's a man it could be a man but
i think it's i don't like to be chicken
like it's so well i think he's it's
writing a
unicorn or something
how how high are you gonna stack those
yo you you're you currently have joe
rogan nipples
that's crazy all right
chicken
oh
you guys got me [ __ ] we got you you got
me okay that's definitely like it's got
to be a guy because it's on a cutting
board yeah it looks like a guy yeah
that's like that's throwing us off
that's trying to throw us off i it
that's a guy
hold on i'm a yep what the [ __ ]
win
[Applause]
i'm on a cutting board what am i doing
on this cutting board huh
that's you doing an italian accent and
is that racist this is a person i think
is it racist for me to do italian accent
italians are not white this might be a
person i have no [ __ ] clue but i'm
gonna go with chicken because we've seen
a person left that's a chicken in the
space
this is chicken okay i mean you guys
were
there's a chicken skiing wow chickens
don't ski that's why it was hard
15 more holy [ __ ]
each each thing is three images so okay
yeah
um that'd be
like a chicken and a toilet
uh that's gonna be a human because
that's the jabate it's gonna it looks
like it's a chicken so it's gonna be i
think it's a guy also i think it's a
head maybe i'm calling chicken i need a
dub because you guys got a point on me
yep dude you got what the [ __ ] man
on the plate i'm on a plate now we're
going down here finding where are you
finding all these shirtless old white
guys what do you search for on youtube
you search for like
boomer or like what do you look for ian
how'd you find him
uh just old man stock photos old man
stock photo guy
i'm on a plate what's going on who put
me on this plate
[Music]
how about this
that's chicken
dude i don't even know what i'm looking
at that's an old guy
it's like an old guy looking at a webcam
jerking off and you could just talk
about it
yeah that's an omegle shot like that so
that's that's the chicken then okay you
said old guy so i'm gonna go with
chicken i'm gonna go with the opposite
old guy
at a swimming pool or don't worry it's
like a stadium or something oh man like
my ridge heads fell
my friends did this looks like chicken
i'm gonna say chicken
hmm i have no idea hold on chicken
i feel like it's the chicken breasts
posing weird like
oh yeah chicken breast
oh no oh
damn
they got me in the coop
mario guys clapping we all lost i think
this is the last one
that's chicken
really i don't know
i don't know
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] there's a man i think it's a
chicken
i'm with you
that's a chicken it's donald trump
wow it's really hard to tell the
difference between uncooked chicken and
white and shirtless white guys it really
is this is the last one right here
what god's [ __ ] is that
chad is also having a very hard time it
seems that's tough
uh i don't even know where i'm looking
at i don't know this
i think it's rows of chicken
oh multiple chickens like they're
hanging from the from i could see it i
think it's a human
i don't know how to do that i'm not
[Applause]
all right
well done love him and how much is that
out
good price
three 395.
so there's that
and then uh we do have one other thing
too uh
it is also relatively quick
okay that yeah take about the same i
love the one where they look the same
yeah that's that's the one right i love
that i've done that before this one is
surprising
oh [ __ ] yeah it's so hard so here's the
gallery so here we go let me
set this up here
just an update drops of jupiter is about
the lead singer's dead mother oh
that's the same concept
is that his mother
that she passed away from yeah here she
is this is she's so pretty
okay so that's the same person no that's
a different person
what is jessica chastain right is that
her name um i think it's the girl named
this looks like a
different hmm he's a different person
straight up i don't know because when
you the way you smile can make your your
nose shape changing one is independent
wait are we trying to guess if it's the
same person or not yeah the same person
or not oh it's not the same person i
don't think it's a yeah there's it's two
people
i think i think they're different people
the only way it would be the same is if
she contoured her face differently
[Music]
hassan
i already said it is not the same person
okay yeah i gave you who the person
those are indeed different people that's
jessica
and bryce but they do look powerful
even though she was you know doing agile
for the american state department
the one on the left she was in jurassic
park right i don't know i've never seen
that
but i'm talking wait that was the other
girl
or someone else which one was bryce
dallas you said there was already
oh yeah that's neither of them no way oh
there's another redhead girl who was in
jurassic park that's not on screen the
girl on the right was a dress oh that is
the girl on the right my bad on the
right oh that was the girl on the right
yes oh so interesting yes they look
similar
so interesting all right next
not different people actually i think
that's the same
really i don't know because they're
different i know one oh wait a minute no
no that's different one natalie portman
one's keira knightley yeah yeah they're
different they're different they're
different that's interesting they almost
got you forgot they look the same yeah
because they actually were
stunned she was a stunt double for uh
her well that's some double the decoy
padme's decoy in uh that's right
wait for real yeah yeah i didn't know
that nerd i am a nerd do you like star
wars i love star wars oh interesting
yeah keira knightley they're about the
same agency here at nightly make an
appearance when she she wasn't famous
yet and she was like
i had a little yeah she wasn't like
famous yet she didn't have her pirates
of the caribbean uh role yet but she was
the queen
the one in the costume while padme was
running around that's awesome yeah
nice little trivia yep
same person that's the same [ __ ]
uh
i mean the nose looks the same that's
the same [ __ ]
we're kind of crushing this but it's the
same person it looks like the same our
white doll is on
facial hair non-facial hair and then
hair is slightly different i know here
it does it's the that's right both of
them are adam scott yeah and we love him
don't we yeah
okay ian this is whoever he looks better
with facial hair
yeah yeah i agree okay
yeah i mean different different color
eyes that one's old they have different
color eyes you guys
that's a giveaway no that's yeah can you
can you watch it
on the left right yeah i think that's
amy and then on the uh right yeah then
amy adams that's right you got it
but
incredibly similar looking like yeah wow
like from behind probably like like the
same hairstyle and kind of like whoa
yeah
oh
yeah come on left you got
liberals uh the biggest nightmare susan
sarandon really why everybody hates her
because she voted for bernie sanders
because she she's a bernie supporter oh
and she she said she was gonna vote
third party in 2016 and liberals never
forgave her they still talk about it
they talk about it like [ __ ] boomers
talk about jane fonda right and then
sigourney weaver i never gave up on you
jane fonda you [ __ ] like that sort of i
actually don't think they look that
similar these things i don't think they
do yeah no
i've seen worse what these are different
people i don't even know what
well i think this is the same person but
i don't know who she is you think he's
the same person i do actually
race i feel like i could not no
one just has more highlighter and
lighting i think it's yeah probably the
same but she has her hair different it's
a hairstyle it's a makeup thing i don't
know who she is
but the noses look the same like the
same shirt that's how you get me okay
because i have face blindness and if i
don't know someone if i don't know like
a celebrity i'm gonna this is i don't
know who should i've never seen her
before in my life but also this is a
different person is that your final
that's 100 okay so we're saying i think
it's the same yeah i'm saying same you
got it right that's uh liam michelle
one person one person oh come on
got him there's different people
they're just different people this guy
ledger and joseph whatever his name is
joseph lamo [ __ ] weirdo
no he's fine i just don't like him for
some reason
who was a participant media guy wait
this one is throwing me off here no it's
uh that's i think that's different
people yes is it i don't know oh my god
oh my god definitely different people
chelsea handler and
uh modern family mom
no it's not no that's not her
that's not the modern family mom there's
no way okay it's not modern family mom
but it is a different is it what's her
name mccourtney what was her [ __ ] jenny
mccartney
[Music]
i actually think it might be the same
person
no i don't know it's hard to tell
because like to me the nose looks
different but it could also be angle and
lighting
dude what the [ __ ]
she's like the judd apatow chick right
no she's not i think they're different
people yeah you've got the wrong person
am i just naming every blonde woman
right now
no the one on the right is def the one i
love is definitely chelsea uh yeah
handler
so it might be chelsea handler younger
on the right
that's what i'm saying like that might
be a 15. no i don't want to hear a guy i
think that's like the judd apatow lady
it's not i think they're just different
people but i'm saying the same person
i'm [ __ ] doing it i'm saying same
different final answers
i'm saying different okay
what do you say what are you talking
about they are different people
and it's chelsea handler and elizabeth
banks
go
i think you're talking about
oh wait never mind
can you pull up another photo leslie
mann is judd uptow's wife i don't know
if that's who you're talking no no no no
no she's like always the female love
interest in a lot of apatow and like
seth rogen movies and [ __ ] like that
right oh he's right yeah four year old
virgin too let me see another photo of
her this is this is her
huh right shoes and four-year-old
birdman yeah a few others oh her with
the short hair god damn
you like the short hair i do like it
yeah i don't i don't care
okay well [ __ ] me there you go
that's crazy what the [ __ ] dude that is
insane
i know that they're different people i
know that they're different people but
that's insane yeah that's insane it
looks the one i know the guy on the
right is javier bardema the guy on the
left looks like an ai generated
look-alike
looks like him with like with a
straighter nose
that's got to suck dude when you're like
literally the clone of a [ __ ]
you know method actor someone more
famous yeah
you're just like [ __ ] well i mean i
guess you're still like super attractive
and you're still like doing movies yeah
that sucks
you think it's such i'm kidding i think
what sucks is like the third uh being
the third hemsworth brother
oh there's a third one exactly exactly
rough yeah the way you just said that is
you know that might suck i don't know if
he's not good he's just not
he's just not no he's in he's in well he
might be a third baldwin i mean the
third hemsworth brother i think was in
hbo's uh westworld yeah can we get all
not famous enough for most people to
know yeah i didn't know there was a
third hemsworth yeah
um yeah i mean the third the further you
get away from alec baldwin the more
[ __ ] up they get
let me see these goons oh one of them
short yeah that's what i'm saying it's
like the oldest oh i know oh he was
great in westworld yeah that's what i'm
saying i liked him in westworld and but
i will say and you didn't even know he
was a [ __ ] hemsworth brother bro bro
i was wasting my life watching that show
not knowing he was a hemsworth why did
he get [ __ ] with the little king jean
short king
this short king i mean he's probably not
even sure because they're like six four
how tall is the
the they're tall no no how tall is the
little the little one he's doing five
nine bro five nine that's still tall for
me the brothers are like six four well
not for a guy that's not tall
especially when your brothers are like
massive greek gods and you're like why
am i five nine
like what the oh
that's cute though i guess five nine's
cute okay we like that we like we like
short kings
ethan is even
stop
feels short king valor i've never said i
was sure he straight up does
okay his brothers are 6'3
how do you be five nine and both your
brothers are six three i don't know
that's the [ __ ] they just date i
don't know i think five nine is nice
because i feel like if you get too much
above six feet though then i'm just
greeted with balls when i hug you know
what i mean like there's a point where
it's too tall too much balls in the face
yeah exactly
who's clapping back there maybe
you're just saying that because you
don't want to turn any of your sims off
no i actually do like
like like under six foot
under six foot you're [ __ ] just
saying that no i'm actually serious okay
i mean if it's true then god bless dude
under six foot dab bod
not dead out of shape please take care
of yourself
so these two guys
it's different it's different yeah we're
saying it's different it's different
yeah jeffrey dean morgan and javier
let's go that one is amazing come on
javier bardem is [ __ ] you know
these are different and it's interesting
because i know these i don't think these
women really look similar but in this
photo they do that's of course demi
moore and uh
what's her damn face i look different
different people what's your face on the
left i don't know oh no you know her
she's super famous i don't know either
of these women and i thought that they
were the same woman
but they're definitely not if i don't
know them i just like it's the same
woman
these photos are just are deceptive
what's her name on the left like she's
super famous she was in uh
uh whatever they're different the final
answer all right they are different this
is jennifer connolly jennifer connolly
yes uh and demi moore as you said
uh how about these two guys
oh come on
different the lip sizes
they're very clearly different ones uh
what's this zach braff and then the
other one is uh
the the
husband of that other woman he's a
podcast guy he's a podcast and he is a
podcast yeah but with all that being
said these are two similar [ __ ]
looking white guys and they also
literally play the same role in like
they smile the same way i mean it's it's
it's insane and their hairline is the
same
these guys these are a bunch of crackers
there's a couple of crackers in the tub
you mean right he's high off he's high
up the jacuzzi supply we have too many
[ __ ] these are you know you get
a pack of crackers all right
ritz
there was a lot there's a lot of good
ones from a clip i found oh jesus christ
christ so yes that is zac graf and dak
shepard is the other guy i love that
that's a sick name though dak [ __ ] [ __ ]
same guy stanley tucci that's the same
[ __ ] and you know what we stan
in this [ __ ]
our group chat without you like the the
employee group chat is the house of
touches
he's a character actor that's been in
like 10 billion movies yeah the only
reason why i know it is there's a new
netflix show with him where he's like i
think eating food in italy or something
yeah and my dad was watching it the
other night and i just immediately i'm
like that's stanley tucci
i don't think i've ever seen him as like
a main character but he's been many like
supporting characters exactly he's that
kind of guy he's oh he's in everything
but all right to the touch
oh stop it uh
uh are they that's not jeff is that jeff
bridges it's not the same is that the
same no that's right no that is the same
you can't be serious right now no no no
no no that's the same guy you racist
i don't think so
you you crafted hate and
okay bro no that's uh that's jeff
bridges and uh what's his [ __ ] name
russell yeah jeff bridges and jeff
bridges
uh what's his name god damn no shot
these are different people he played uh
he played wyatt earp and [ __ ] he's are
you serious yeah this is literally the
same guy with glasses two different guys
no the nose is different i think i feel
like i'm going crazy right now
it's this it's too difficult
people
jeff bridges and uh
straight up the same person that's my
final call on this i think you guys are
wrong he i love him he's a great actor
on the left
you got it ethan or you were close it's
kurt russell
oh kurt russell yeah
are you guys sure white god
i i feel like there's there's call me
white god now hassan
uh what
i don't know what is this is the same
person with hair dye no she's not i
think you might be right no
[ __ ] shot these are different people
no the eye shape is the same though the
eyebrow location is the same the nose
tip is the same just a different angle
and now analysis the cis it's in one she
has more of a tan with dark hair and the
other she has really blinding white
lights on her and uh her hair is lighter
this is why i love i love bangs if
that's true what you're saying i mean
that's
that's what i see anyways i could be
wrong i'm just like the same person
you're a different person
that is dakota johnson twice
okay dude why do you always stand up
when i lay down
[Applause]
[Laughter]
there's a there's a balance it's like i
know i'm it's just a pool i just i'm all
over the place i'm sorry same person uh
no
people it's different people oh come on
that's katy perry on the left
no that's the [ __ ] new girl
that's katy perry and they're
what's her [ __ ] name
no
it's two different people for sure
that's katy perry
no she's lying dude that's literally
carried katy perry two different people
yeah this pool up he's like
completely deflated
this is horrible the cracker pool is not
good yeah
how are you gonna get rid of all these
they got a dumpster in the back of the
building and there's some hungry you're
going to throw the whole hot tub away
just
how are you guys getting rid of this
just dump it
yeah i mean i'm not eating it come on
you guys don't waste food eat this
just put it in a trash can and leave it
in the middle of the office and we'll
munch on it
you could bottle them up in the jars and
then sell them
right yeah we could sell them yeah
there's that okay just use ritz crackers
all right it's two different people
i'm sorry it's two different people it's
zoe deschanel zoe the
new girl as you said that one's katy
perry
i don't think that's what katy perry
looks like
okay there's different people draco
malfoy and aaron paul
i didn't realize they look so similar
but yeah two different people
i don't think they look that similar
nailed it
if i know a celebrity it's over it's a
wrap yeah except i i guess i don't know
what [ __ ] katy perry looks like
oh two different people
that's funny
no
david spade is getting and keith urban
oh that's who that is on the right on
the right yeah you are from texas he is
a country singer but he's from australia
oh that's the word god you got
australians [ __ ] taking over country
how did americans let that die he did he
is pretty good that's what i'm saying
americans that's how you know i was down
in the pool
you know the cowboys of the south i was
chewing on some kangaroo meat yeah
more badass cowboys wait does he have
like a country twang when he [ __ ]
sings or is he just a little baby
a little egg
it sounds country like you wouldn't know
he's australian if you didn't know yeah
you got it oh my god so he's like fakes
his accent you can't twink you can't do
country you're not twang it up i'm just
trying to do like i mean australians
kind of have to die
i love my tractor
come on down by the bobby yeah won't you
take a ride on my big green tractor
we can
you guys uh yes uh you were right david
spade keith urban
um
now
it's time to kick it up to hard mode
oh my god this wasn't hard oh yeah no
this is this is this is easy [ __ ] for a
challenging one yeah go ahead all right
here we go
no
this one i can't tell the difference
this is harvey weinstein
they're both harvey do you think they're
both harvey weinstein
i feel like they're probably
the same just because you gave us two
pickers that look very different and
you're trying to trick us
well i might there's i don't think
there's a trick here i think right is
harvey weinstein obviously
and on the left i think is harvey like a
little younger maybe oh you think age
gap it's just an age gap situation
interesting
is that your final answer yeah well
i'm afraid one of them the one on the
left is ryan cavanaugh god damn it oh
this one is so
weird oh no this was the hardest one
yeah oh there's a website for this if
you google
ryan kavanagh
and then scroll down everyone watching
follow these instructions oh yeah right
now look like harvey weinstein
spent some time on the website reading
familiarized no it's not an ad oh okay
we made this website to help people no
there's a difference between oh a lot of
people have problems telling them apart
on the left side
you made this website on the right is
harvey weinstein because there's this
guy ryan kavanagh a lot of people
mistaken for harvey weinstein based on
the physical appearance and we thought
we should um help the public clarify for
the sake of ryan here they are they are
close friends with one another though
well here's ryan kavanaugh kissing
harvey weinstein of all people on the
head at that i mean you wouldn't want
anyone to see that photo that's why we
circled it in red and we're saying
making sure two people that there's two
different people like he's not kissing
himself obviously no one makes it yeah
that would be really difficult to do
so anyways that's that's the game that
was uh the only that was the only
challenge
okay
i mean we failed that one [ __ ]
yeah
so uh i think that's it that's all
that's all we have all right well this
is the cracker experience the cracker
extravaganza
yeah thank you for coming thanks for
having me amaranth
hassan as always
uh congratulations to zach the whitest
thank you thank you very much thank you
thank you wow what a joy what a pleasure
it's been guys that's it that's it for
the leftovers this year that's right
yeah
we have plenty of leftovers
[Music]
[Laughter]
so next year
we'll be back on the when are we back
then the leftovers uh
uh what he said
no it's a little bit later than that
well 17 is when we're going to film it i
think so 20. oh right yeah so 20 yeah
he's right yeah so so we'll be back now
then
but uh we'll be back tomorrow for after
dark and we'll see you then thank you to
all everybody what a joyous time
um i hope to never see another ritz
cracker
yeah this is traumatized me i feel like
i don't want to eat ritz crackers ever
again like get a shot of the pool you
got to see how [ __ ]
this [ __ ] is
just i worked it's coming up
pants and it was the dumbest decision
i've made you've got to stand up and
show it's in literally every crevice of
my corduroy yeah stand up and show it
i will i'm waiting for the big shot here
i want to get i want to
do this to myself here's for the comedic
effect you know
the comedic effect i feel like this is
bad for your skin too is this so oh sure
sure there's nothing good oh thank you
so much for your help yeah go ahead just
get that in there
yeah so
this is the pool this is the cracker hot
tub experience it's been a good time
it's been a swell time it's in every one
of my is like straight up in in the in
the crevices of the [ __ ] corduroy it
is terrible look at my pants bro goddamn
dude i'm gonna get up right now i do you
guys have like a dyson
i want you guys to suck me off with the
both of you are like
well she was sitting on a pillow she was
sitting she wasn't committed
she's a fake cracker
all right thanks guys
[Music]
[Music]
you